foreign
if you're just joining us Rudy Giuliani
is sweating his face off explaining to
us why Trump really won the election
again inspectors every state
almost every approved this
thrown away
gone for eternity is this a skit the
only thing left is to prevent a dead
person that could have been not filled
out Friday he's saying there was a dead
person in the envelope
Rudy's about to have actual drops of
sweat coming off of his brow I mean is
this a normal amount I don't know how
hot it is in the room but this something
seems very wrong here we'll be in the
lawsuit that comes out dude he's melting
Arizona is a state that we're looking at
very very carefully strongly looking at
it I would say we're probably I assume
oh my God she's working or she's working
for this
I'd like to read them all to you but I
don't have the time
you should have had the time and energy
to go look for that
oh
the mangoes my bags of mangoes
[Music]
I love mangoes too
okay
now that we are up under our body's
regime my bag of mangoes now costs
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
bag of mangoes mango art mangoes like a
free boxy that's it eight or eleven
bucks
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mangoes
welcome everybody we're standing by
imminently for the sentencing of the
three men convicted in the killing of
Ahmad Arbury we covered this case at the
conclusion of the Written House case you
might remember we went right into the
Arbury case and all three men were
convicted and we are now just moments
away from their sentencing these are
serious crimes and we're expecting
serious sentences to be perfectly honest
with you just as a reminder uh the
guilty verdicts were read
um about five weeks ago
all right I'm going to go ahead and
address each one of these verdict forms
separately first verdict form I have is
the state of Georgia versus Travis
McMichael Mr McMichael just please stand
verdict is as follows
in the superior court of Glenn County
state of Georgia the state of Georgia
versus Travis McMichael
case number cr00433
jury verdict form count one malice
murder
we the jury find the defendant Travis
McMichael guilty
I'm gonna ask that whoever just made it
out first be removed from the court
please all right so we won't we're not
going to watch the entire thing because
this is about to start but just a
reminder that's the those are the guilty
verdicts that we are talking about and
imminently we are going to get the
sentences and we are monitoring four
different feeds for you and one is
already live in the room
um we're gonna see what sort of
sentences these are and it's expected to
be pretty pretty serious if you have
thoughts uh super chats are live on
screen there just aren't any we've got a
temporary solution to the systemic
problem with super chat but they will
show up over there at a certain point I
want to say thank you to indiceso for
the twitch Prime subscription you're
number one today by the way I do want to
say this is a serious thing yesterday
was our biggest Day on YouTube since
January 18th of 2021 almost most a year
the the biggest day we had on YouTube
yesterday an incredible day and many of
you were here for the January 6th
anniversary stream we also had like
three or four different clips due very
very well and I from what I'm looking at
here yeah two million views in one day
on uh YouTube yesterday and that is the
the biggest day since let me see if this
is right
January 18th yeah
January 18th wow so I really very much
appreciate that
um there's someone saying David are you
going to talk about how January 6 wasn't
an Insurrection this is the first time
they've ever chatted they've only been
following since a minute ago and they
are immediately banned I can just tell
we we just don't need you here
uh you can you can move along and troll
elsewhere I also want to say thanks to
Jen here on Twitch for um the the gift
of a twitch subscription very very much
appreciate that again if you're just
joining us we are standing by for the
sentencing of the three men already
convicted in the killing of Ahmad arbory
we have some live updates from CNN here
um
let's see what we have attorney for one
of the killers praises the judge on his
way to the sentencing hearing
uh okay I have no doubt he will give
Roddy Brian the individualized sentence
that he deserved that's Kevin Guff told
reporters Guff said he plans on filing
some motions regarding the sentencing
ahead of the hearing challenging the
Court's ability to sentence to life in
prison that's going to be interesting to
hear as well Brian is one of three men
convicted Travis McMichael and Gregory
McMichael will be sentenced today
alongside Brian Ahmad arbory's mother
says there's nothing the defendants can
say that would make me feel better that
is understandable I really don't want to
hear anything from Travis I really don't
want to hear anything from either
defendants there's nothing they can tell
me today that would make me feel better
I miss Ahmad more and more each day
um this this is going to be intense this
is going to be intense and we are now it
looks like we're getting very very close
to the start of this
see if there's any audio in the room not
quite yet uh but if you have thoughts
feel free to send them I also want to
say thank you to Bob Zilla bobzilla with
a twitch Prime subscription really
appreciate that
um over there uh what coupon codes are
available that's a good question well
one coupon code that's available is
right above my head and it's Obama Obama
if you're wondering where that came from
this is the these are the oranges of
Obama
if Ted doesn't win your second amendment
is going to be in trouble big trouble
remember that O'Rourke voted against the
border wall oh that's a good thing to
him he voted against Kate's law and
for Obama
amnesty okay so that's the origin of
that and it's hard to watch that and uh
and not uh be extremely triggered but
you can use that code on my website
um gamer pigeon says David check out Dr
John Campbell on YouTube he does daily
data analysis of Omicron yeah I I know
about Dr John Campbell and important by
the way I say this not as a joke Dr John
Campbell is not a medical doctor I'm not
saying that to validate or invalidate
anything he says it's just a fact
he is not a medical doctor it's it's
binary you either are a medical doctor
or you are not and he is not and and he
does some good videos he seemed to go in
a little heavy on Ivermectin and make of
it what you will it's he's just not a
medical doctor and that's a fact that is
not not something we can deny at this
point in time
um I want to say thanks to Jen here for
gifting another subscription via twitch
thank you very much Jen will I give a
free clothing item to the first person
to sign up on my website sure yeah sure
first person to sign up at
joinpakman.com you can get a uh you can
get a free item from my online store I
thought Obama was from Molina stream
very much not Molina took it from
Stephen Kenneth Destiny Bonnell II who
took it from me it was uh it was a
felony meme jacking felony meme jacking
took place there thanks to pillar 01 for
the twitch Prime subscription very much
appreciate that as well
um other super chats no not quite yet
there's people arguing in the chat about
whether Dr John Campbell is a medical
doctor guys he doesn't even claim to be
a medical doctor he's just he's just not
a matter it's not a big deal doesn't
mean he's right or wrong he's just not a
medical doctor it's some people are
medical doctors and some people are not
um
geez it's like everybody's getting so
bent out of shape over it
wild wild times
um okay if you're just joining us you
haven't missed anything we're standing
by for the sentencing of the three men
convicted of murdering Ahmad Arbury
those men are I always forget the names
Travis McMichael and his father Gregory
McMichael and Roddy Brian Roddy Brian
was the neighbor
also convicted
um other super chats William hanchey
sending a two dollar Super Chat thank
you very much I appreciate that
right it's like we don't need to give a
list of everybody who's not a medical
doctor just some people aren't medical
doctors and that's fine there are many
different professions that people people
can have
um okay
I want to say thank you to Ryan Bell
Ryan just signed up on my website using
the coupon code Obama
and his new member number six Ryan you
get a free item from my online store
check out davidpackman.com gear pick out
what you like email info
davidpackman.com and we will get that
out to you also thanks to K gouldi for
gifting a subscription upcoming streams
um by the way Dr John Campbell also not
a doctor of economics
okay so just just another thing to
mention
um upcoming streams oh hold on Geo says
good morning sir have you seen the
Tucker Ted interview it was a bloodbath
um I saw a little bit of it yeah in fact
let me send myself a note right now for
covering it Monday too because I've
already filmed the fried the Today's
Show Tucker Ted Cruz interview it almost
seems like in the interview the Dynamics
are that Tucker is sort of like the
the alpha did you guys get that
impression where Ted Cruz is sort of
subservient to Tucker in uh in a lot of
different ways
Steven says hi from Westchester New York
great to hear from you Stephen uh very
very glad to have you here
okay upcoming streams Tuesday January 11
6 p.m will be the David Pacman chess
tournament you can pre-register just by
joining our club on chess.com at
davidpackman.com chess here it is about
150 additional people joining the club
in the last day
um open to everybody very casual
doesn't as long as you know how the
pieces move you can play you'll be
matched up against people of your skill
level it's going to be fun that's 6 p.m
Eastern on Tuesday January 11th and then
next Saturday we are going to be
covering this completely hair brained
rally in Arizona where Donald Trump will
be speaking expected to make some major
announcements as well as people like
Michael Flynn I don't know if pillow is
speaking but there's going to be a bunch
of uh people so that'll be on the
um Saturday January 15th and between now
and then we're going to have other
streams as well
a cryptogram says sir do you have any
predictions for What sentences will be
no I don't we're going to know very soon
and it seems imprudent to guess
David I want to say thanks to all the
great job you've been doing keep it up
thank you Gene
very much appreciate that
very very much appreciate that
um when is it starting right now
right now
it's it's it's happening right now
um
we've got multiple streams here that we
are monitoring it's happening right now
thanks to Crystal drama free for
resubbing Via twitch I very much
appreciate that you're number eight
today
did I see the channel 5 q Anon Shaman
jail interview I did and it's pretty
interesting
it's pretty interesting
um hold on did I have anything else for
you guys oh yeah I mean listen there's a
bunch of Republicans that are still just
sort of like siding with the rioters
here's Josh Hawley on Fox news earlier
this morning and let me just say this it
is a constitutional right to engage in
peaceful political demonstrations and
the thousands tens of thousands of
people who came to Washington last
January 6th and have now been harassed
by the FBI have had people knock on
their doors and threaten them that is
crazy and it it's funny because these
people don't care about that at all and
700 people were charged 700 people were
charged it's disgusting they're on the
side of the rioters guys he is wrong it
is wrong to go after law-abiding
citizens right and 700 people have been
charged for crimes based on the evidence
and that is perfectly legal
peaceful it's like okay they're like
well the people that just went to the
Trump rally and then went home
shouldn't be they are law abiding right
but they also haven't been charged
they've been harassed okay give a
specific example some people have been
questioned and interviewed for sure but
they've not been charged uh these people
are truly truly unbelievable
um
um okay
thanks very much do I have yeah let's do
a couple voicemails because it's been so
long since I've been able to do
voicemails I've got 700 unlistened to
voicemails uh I do have one from Whitney
to kick off the year
so I was doing
um
with some really interesting equations
and observations
um so some of these like culminations
are the same so I like grouped them
together there's like uh intj entj isfp
okay it's too early in the morning for
that uh here's another caller
hi David
um
so I was
um in watching the live stream uh
yesterday and
um I saw some people in the chat talking
about how the member uh videos aren't
showing up the newer ones and um
admittedly yeah we it's 2022 so you got
to switch on the website I don't know
how many of you know that we have a
membership program on our website I
mentioned it so infrequently that most
of you probably haven't heard of that
but one of the great benefits of it is
you get the full show six hours earlier
instead of having to wait for piecemeal
Clips like instead of the crumbs you get
the the meat or the cake we might say
because it is now 2022 you do have to
look under the 2022 section
for the 2022 content the 2021 content is
under 2021 the 2022 content is under
2022.
um just uh just so people know just so
people know
let's see what else we have from the
standpoint of callers
oh hold on other super chats coming in
how do you think the Supreme Court will
rule regarding vaccine mandates thanks
from rally LeBron is the goat David
Pacman is the goat I don't know I'm
anxious to see and we may switch to that
after this uh I do have that stream here
all people from coming into the
workplace I think that is so we are
going to switch over to that after the
sentencing but we are handling the
sentencing first lest anyone be
concerned that we are not going to get
to that
uh oh oh no oh no okay let me clarify
because I'm seeing confusion here
if you use a discount code on my website
you don't get a free t-shirt okay if so
the t-shirts cost us I think it's like
17 bucks you know we don't make a lot of
money on the t-shirts I think we make
seven dollars if you only pay a dollar
eighty a month for a membership I can't
give you a free t-shirt because we lose
money
you know we are trying to fund raise
here not fund deplete so if you want a
free t-shirt get a membership at full
price for the year it's 60 bucks I'll
send you a free T-shirt If you use a
discount code like Obama Obama or wow 22
that's great but we can't also give you
the free t-shirt because then we just
lose money
and you can't be wearing a t-shirt when
you use any of these codes that's
exactly right you have to be wearing
sweatshirts or sweaters otherwise uh
right I know how dare I not lose money
on every membership I should be losing
12. every time someone signs up we
should be losing 12 bucks that's that's
that's
fair
that seems perfectly reasonable and
sensible
okay uh why hasn't it started guys I
don't know it was scheduled for 10.
there's clearly people in the room
um
we will get to the Supreme Court after
the fact
Dear God
uh should be any minute should be any
minute everybody everybody relax
everybody relax okay a few other super
chats I'm sorry voicemails let's see
what we got here oh there you go again
with your views of people against
vaccines Troy York is so mush-mouthed I
can barely understand what he ever says
I don't believe it I think it's online
um the actual dangers are not too facing
not vaccinated the actual dangers are
the psychopaths in the media and
governments who want to jab everyone in
the arm this is what is a real issue you
are a propagandist hack prompt again
scumbag
um I am a scumbag but I'm not a
propagandist you're celebrating these
deaths the for all we know these people
may have been removed no every time I
talk about an anti-vaxx person who has
died I say I find it sad I don't
celebrate it unfortunately we're gonna
have to move on because other than
calling me a scumbag everything else in
that voicemail is completely untrue
completely untrue
uh
oh hold on a second I think we have to
I think we have to ban a few people
man there's there's just a lot of trolls
here today it's really disappointing
oh man
oh do I have any unbans that's a fair
question let me take a look at that
uh
uh yes I do
so let's see here
a user came in
and said a user using the username
Hillary R Clinton came in and said fauci
had a lab in Wuhan that tested gain of
function years before and was never
disclosed thanks CNN Trump is likely a
black hat pretending to be a white hat
the white hats are winning the battle so
it's all coming out regarding voting
recalls and the illegitimacy of the
election they were banned for spreading
election disinformation and then their
unban request is simply the word weak so
that is going to be a permaban
um man there's a lot of a lot of really
really toxic people out there
very very toxic
it's like not even interesting you know
okay
in fact my here's a better analogy than
your suit of Iron
Man now we're off Troy York
see what else we got here
uh David he just keeps calling in my God
any of the patent money
I have my beer okay he just won't stop
won't stop calling in agunil says Troy
York sounds like he pops a handful of
benzos before calling well he said here
that he's drinking alcohol
or alcohol as some of our callers
pronounce it uh yeah I don't know what
else to make of it
yeah I do feel stupider for listening
let's take a let's let's listen to a
normal voicemail okay
let's see
see what this is up to
ooh normal voicemail not playing Let me
refresh here
uh here we go
hi David this is an anonymous tip the
wood chipper and the leaf blower sounds
are actually a plot by the Deep state to
try to disrupt your broadcast yeah that
I agree with your broadcast was totally
unwatchable
um I couldn't hear the sounds but
um I knew I could see the irritation
um on you and and I just I couldn't
watch one second about of the broadcast
um just the way the Deep State intended
yep no that's totally sensible sure sure
yep very very good that's a powerful
voicemail really good point
uh David how have you been managing your
mental health during the pandemic
basically fine yeah I mean uh you know I
uh
take long walks on the beach and go out
every day and do do my stuff take
weekends off from politics
I'd say pretty well
pretty well overall
I might yeah right the Deep State went
after me but I'm part of the deep State
that's true
uh Mike pillow said uh The subpoena is
corrupt I I wasn't even in the Capitol
on the sixth that doesn't sound like a
very good legal argument to me I mean in
fact yes you're right Mike pillow's
legal arguments are not typically
substantive
uh
I completely agree with you completely
agree with you
let's see what else we've got here
you know Pac-Man I oh this is the San
Antonio troll thank you for a very long
time and I try like every year to give
you the benefits of that I'm like you
know a new year I'm gonna watch some
Pac-Man and you know maybe you know I
like I try hard to like you man
um but you are just a bloodthirsty
Maniac you were crossing your fingers
that something happened there was a riot
or something today on the anniversary of
the worst attack in human history or
whatever the hell you did anyone did
anyone who watched yesterday's stream
Come Away with the impression that I
wanted there to be a riot
does anybody remember that part of the
stream I don't remember that
this guy seems very very obsessed with
me
instead of accidents because it wasn't
the worst attack of human history not
even close it's not even an attack there
was a bunch of rioters again this guy is
known for calling in and criticizing me
for things I never said I never called
it the worst attack in human history
it's very weird a bunch of morons but
you play it up to be that there was this
massive like catastrophe you know that's
a thousand times worse than 911 a
thousand that's not this show no so the
thing about the San Antonio troll is uh
he calls in and criticizes me for things
that I've never said and that aren't on
this show John asking via Super Chat
what are you thinking about Ted Cruz
letting Tucker Carlson cuck him out on
his show yesterday it was pretty wild
let's see if I can find a clip
um
Tucker Ted Cruz will watch like one clip
here as we wait
last night I sent you a text shortly
thereafter and said listen I'd like to
go on because the way I phrased things
yesterday it was sloppy and it was
frankly dumb and so here is uh Ted Cruz
doing his makeup to Tucker he's got to
get back on Tucker's good side look at
Tucker's face by the way I don't buy
that I don't buy that for look I've
known you a long time since before you
went to the Senate your Supreme Court
Contender you take words as seriously as
any man who's ever served in the Senate
that's a lie and every word you repeated
that phrase I do not believe that you
used that accidentally I just don't it's
so Tucker as a result of my sloppy
phrasing it's caused a lot of people to
misunderstand what I meant let me tell
you what what I meant to say
what I was referring to I guess also I
would want an explanation as to why he
was unable to say what he meant to say
did something affect him yesterday where
he tried to say one thing and he
couldn't like that's I meant to say
something different well but why didn't
you are the limited number of people who
engaged in violent attacks against
police officers I think you and I both
agree that if you assault a police
officer you should go to jail that's who
I was talking about and does Tucker
agree with that I think it depends what
the police officer is doing and whether
the person doing the attacking is a
trumpist the reason the phrasing was
sloppy is I have talked dozens if not
hundreds of times I've drawn a
distinction I wasn't saying that the
thousands of peaceful protesters
supporting Donald Trump are somehow
terrorist I wasn't saying the millions
of of Patriots across the country
supporting president Trump no one
thought that's what he was saying that's
the funny thing Iris and that's what a
lot of people have misunderstood that
wait a second but even your way back
hold on what you just said doesn't make
sense so if somebody assaults right
Tucker is correctly
realizing that Ted Cruz is lying and
he's now just changing his tune because
a lot of people didn't like it Tucker is
right about that cop he should be
charged and go to jail I couldn't agree
more we have said that for years
but that person's still not a terrorist
how many people have been charged with
terrorism on January 6th like why'd you
use that word you're playing into the
other sides characterization that is Joe
Kent just explained allows them to
Define an entire population as foreign
combatants and you know by the way it's
really common that people who commit
what we colloquially refer to as
terrorist attacks after two years of
going through the court system it's very
common that they're not charged with
terrorism that doesn't really tell us
anything about whether we characterize
it as a terrorist act it's not it's not
it's neither here nor there it doesn't
prove or disprove anything that so why'd
you do it so Tucker let me answer you
directly the the reason I use that word
for a decade I have referred to people
who violently assault police officers as
terrorists I've done so over and over
and over again if you look at all the
assaults we've seen across the country
I've called that terrorism over and over
again that being said Tucker I agree
with you it was stake to say that
yesterday and the reason is what you
just said I'm sorry Tucker please take
me back I want to keep texting you which
is we've now had a year of Democrats in
the media twisting words right and
trying to say that all of us are
terrorists trying to say yes that's not
what happened here you're a terrorist
I'm a terrorist and so look I don't like
people who who assault cops and and I
stand up and defend cops and that's not
what this is about really so anyway yeah
total cuckoldry there I mean it's it's
really shocking the degree to which Ted
Cruz is completely subservient to Tucker
very very interesting
um definition of terrorism the unlawful
use of violence and intimidation
especially against civilians in the
pursuit of political aims I mean yeah
but by that definition
by that definition
David on your soundboard you have the
judge saying something about warm food
what is he saying oh yeah
uh let's see I think it's here
oh no
oh
some of these seem to be a
something's wrong with some of my um
soundboard things by the way how are the
calzones in fact we have Subway tomorrow
the food is here
yeah some of them are messed up lunch is
here pizza is here whatever you do make
sure you go to the bathroom yeah
somewhere other than the cartwheel yeah
warm food at noon is not working I'm
gonna need to get it some sometimes like
weirdly named files end up glitching
it's very strange very very strange
welcome everybody if you're just joining
us as we are about to Crest the bottom
of the hour we are standing by for the
sentencing of the three men convicted of
murdering Ahmad Arbury they have all
been convicted that was on November
24th it was right before
the Thanksgiving holiday today Brian
McMichael Travis McMichael and Roddy
Brian will be sentenced it is going to
be any moment we're expecting motions
from that wacky Attorney Kevin Guff who
talked about Colonel Sanders and black
Pastors in church I'm sorry not in
church in Church it would be uh where
you would expect to see them in the
courthouse
um that is going to be momentarily
uh
that's really it I don't know what else
what else there is to say that's kind of
where we are right now if you are
joining and watching on YouTube you can
send me your thoughts about what you
expect the sentence to be via a Super
Chat it'll show up highlighted in green
or orange or even if you send like a big
boy Super Chat it would be in red red is
hard to get to it's tough to achieve red
and of course I invite you to sign up on
my website and support the work we are
doing we are recommitting to very many
live streams as we are now in an
election year yesterday we had our
biggest Day on YouTube dating all the
way back to January 18th of 2021 which
is incredible incredible Jesse says
trying this again you missed my second
Super Chat thanks for your work I only
ask you to invest a moment to learn how
to pronounce raw life
it's raw life isn't it raw egg
it's like a raw leg
that's I that's how I was taught to
pronounce it
uh in Belgium where I grew up Tammy
Sexton has just signed up at
joinpakman.com thank you Tammy so three
options available you sign up and you
pay full price and then you just feel
great about yourself and you can get a
free t-shirt if you pay for the year all
at once you can use the coupon code
Obama Obama or you can use the new
coupon code for the year wow 22 and of
course uh you know the the crazy thing
is we were talking about this uh having
a very very big discussion of this
recently
um
we have had basically every Revenue
Source go to zero before if you remember
adpocalypse 1.0 and the very very low
rent sequel adpocalypse 2.0 we had
YouTube Revenue go to zero overnight if
you remember the twitch bands once for
showing a debate and it was a copyright
related element once for showing The
Written House trial and a gory exhibit
we have had twitch Revenue go to zero if
you remember the Facebook debacle where
we were just banned from posting
anything to Facebook I don't even
remember why at this point in time the
only Revenue Source that's really
protected is the one where we eliminate
anybody between you and me which is our
website uh and so that's why we talk
about signing up at joinpakman.com and I
really appreciate everybody who has we
also are including twitch subscriptions
here and our path to 100 and if you have
Amazon Prime you can sign up for twitch
Prime at no cost to you
we get a little money from Bezos you
take a few bucks from Bezos and you send
it to us it costs you nothing and so
gopher just used their Amazon twitch
Prime subscription here and that moves
us to number 10 which is exciting
Derek gray says elements of bathrooms
please let me see if I have elements of
bathrooms on my soundboard elements of
bathrooms exactly
thanks to rosinantis for the twitch
Prime subscription putting us at 11. 11
is a beautiful number
um will I be updating the soundboard for
2022 absolutely absolutely I have you
know one thing I have not wait what's
this
globalished internationalist trotskyite
socialist shun like Obama Trudeau
mccrone and the rest of these Zio beasts
that's my Alex Jones impression which I
have I do have a lot of new things on
here which I've not necessarily been
using I have an entire George W bush
um section
fool me once shame on shame on you
fool me once shame on shame on you
it fool me We Can't Get Fooled Again
exactly uh let's do one other George W
bush one
see what I got here and one of the
things I've used on the Google is uh to
pull up maps exactly exactly so we have
that
um
I have a couple different ones here
Jeffrey asks about massive dumps yeah I
have a whole dump section actually
big massive dumps dumps
and what happened if you watched the
election I was called by the biggest
people uh saying congratulations
political people congratulations sir you
just won the election it was 10 o'clock
and you looked at the numbers and I'm
sure you felt that way this election was
over and then they did dumps they call
them dumps big massive dumps exactly so
that's a pretty full-on section Charlie
says your Alex Jones sounds like Bernie
I don't hear that at all
let me see globalist internationalist
trotskyite socialists unlike Obama
Trudeau macron and the rest of these Zio
beasts
yeah I do have the nuclear stuff nuclear
proliferation
that's really good
nuclear proliferation that's a good one
nuclear proliferation nuclear energy
nuclear facilities too many OB gyns
aren't able to practice their their love
with women all across this country yeah
that's a and that's a very very sad
thing I want to say thank you to Darth
Evan and Jen here for the two twitch
Prime subscriptions really appreciate
that uh let's see what else we've got
here
David can you use Trump's speech tracker
to find the source of bigly or perhaps
Big League oh that's not a bad idea uh
let's see fact-based Trump search
here it is let's see if I type in bigly
would we be able to find the origin of
that
uh let's see here it is I think
and when we want to compete with
I better not think that way because we
are losing out big league
I'm hearing Big League there I don't
think he's saying bigly I think he's
actually saying Big League
uh
uh let's see if there's other ones
um
let's see here I'm just curious what is
the future of The Apprentice franchise
going to be going oh this would be tough
to find because it's a 10 minute audio
uh we are lowering now let's see what he
says here I can't let's see
tradition coming in what's your what's
your message to them well I think I've
really solved that because you know the
election was not long ago and we had a
great Victory we had a victory that
nobody though was possible 306. uh
remember they said there is no path to
270 for Trump trump can't win because
there's no path and I kept going up to
Maine where Maine had won and we won it
but we didn't need it because we won
Michigan Wisconsin Pennsylvania Florida
we won so many North Carolina
um so you know I I really focused very
heavily on the Latino Community or the
Hispanic community and it was something
that I'm very proud of I'm very proud of
the numbers we got
they want protection and they want jobs
this seems like it might be the wrong
time code
better not think that yeah oh no hold on
I think we are getting to it actually
to take place but this isn't even the
right one hold on let me go back to it
here we go
and they don't want people pouring
across the border that they have no idea
who they are and one of the reasons I
did so well with the Hispanic Community
is the fact that they do want jobs and
they do want protection and they know
that I'm going to take care of that and
I've already been producing the jobs
because Ford and General Motors and and
many other companies even Fiat Chrysler
in terms of in terms of the car
companies but so many other types of
companies they're pouring back into our
country now they want to be here lower
taxes remember how all of these things
were lies anyway so yeah it does seem
like Trump actually says Big League not
big Lee
but they're they're both funny here is
the judge folks here we go uh thanks to
throne alive and frascum and misco for
the twitch Prime subscriptions very much
appreciate that
oh sorry and thanks to Henrik Rin for
the new membership on my website with
the coupon code
[Music]
the judge is very safely masked all
right we are uh back on the state of
Georgia versus Travis McMichael Gregory
McMichael and William R Bryan with the
jury having reached a verdict the court
indicated that it would schedule
sentencing uh the sentencing was noticed
for today
is the state ready to proceed yes your
honor the state is ready to proceed is
Travis McLaughlin ready to proceed yes
Greg McMichael yes and uh Mr Prime yes
you are okay any preliminary Matters
from the state
no preliminary Matters from the state
you're honor study preliminary matterson
trapsody Michael oh yeah Greg McMichael
there we go and Mr Brian
yeah sure um we vow three motions uh
this morning I have a fourth motion to
make orally
um
I'm not going to belabor them at any
great length but I didn't want to have
them on file for the record we filed
this morning a motion to Bar imposition
of sentence of life without the role as
to defendant Brian we expected this
uh that is basically we're arguing for
an extension of the decision of the U.S
Supreme Court in Edmond V Florida which
held that individuals who kill who are
convicted of felony murder without
killing attempting to kill or intending
to kill or not eligible for the death
penalty
we're pursuing that both under the
Eighth Amendment to the United States
constitutional Arthur one section one
paragraphs this is important institution
of the state of Georgia we're asking the
court to extend that reasoning one step
further reflecting evolving standards of
decency and hold that the imposition of
a sentence of life without parole for
felony murder would likewise be
unconstitutionally cruel under our
Constitution's absent evidence that
defendant Brian killed attempted to kill
or intended to kill mod Arbor we don't
believe any of those facts are in
dispute in this case
that's our first motion
anything from the state
[Applause]
this is a big big deal
the reason felony murder is felony
murderers murder and different from
malice murder is because of the lack of
specific intent to commit the murder as
we all know when a co-defendant kills
well when a co-defendant
like two men go into a convenience store
and they attack convenience store clerk
and the clerk defending himself shoots
and kills one of the armed robbers
the first Armed robber is responsible
for the death of his friend and
co-defendant under felony murder because
while there was no intent for one armed
robber to kill the other Armed robber
it's a matter of responsibility under
felony murder not a matter of intent to
kill and in this particular case
Mr Brian is eligible for this court to
impose a sentence of life without the
possibility of parole there is nothing
preventing this court from doing that on
a felony murder charge because felony
murder once again is about
responsibility not about intent to kill
thank you
let's get off
your honor the dog we expecting this
that casket I don't believe it that
response addressed the issue the issue
is force an individual system such as Mr
Brian who did not kill did not attempt
to kill and did not intend to kill
whether or not the eighth amendment
allows the imposition of the sentence of
life without parole is not a question of
the Georgia sentencing scheme or
statutes it's a question of federal
constitutional law clearly under those
circumstances the death penalty
imposition of the death penalty is cruel
and unusual we are contending
since nmd Florida in 1982 that standards
and our sense of decency in society have
evolved to the point where you should
the Eighth Amendment does not allow the
imposition of a sentence of life without
parole for felony murder
killing
and attempt to kill or intend to kill
and I don't think the state contests
that those are not the facts of this
case I think the state is
relying on the fact that the Supreme
Court hasn't addressed the United States
Supreme Court hasn't addressed this
issue yet please add to my knowledge
we're preserving the issue for repeal
all right the court received the Motions
bar in position of sentence of life
without the possibility parole is
defendant Brian felony murderer this
morning it looks like it was filed at 8
18. I have reviewed the motion
cites the one case that was just
referenced by Mr Golf and having
considered the arguments of council the
Court denies the motion wow
wow
thank you honor our second motion is the
motion to declare unconstitutional
mandatory life sentence for felony
murder for a discreet class of offenders
and in the alternative motion of our
imposition of life sentence as to
defendant Brian
the previous motion addressed whether or
not Mr Brian was eligible under the
Eighth Amendment for a sentence of life
without parole this motion challenges
whether Mr Brian can be sentenced to a
mandatory life sentence for felony
murder both as a class of individuals
who have not killed intended to kill or
attempted to kill and also as to Mr
Brian individually and
we contend that this is essentially the
first part of it is taking the Edmund
case that has already been discussed
this morning not one step but two steps
to strike down mandatory felony murder
for people that convicted a felony
murder that fall within that class of
individuals that have not killed
attempts to kill or intended to kill
this is an issue which has tremendous
Import in the state of Georgia and
around the country
in that there are
hundreds in Georgia and probably
thousands of individuals around the
country who are serving life sentences
have been in prison for many many years
who drove the the car that was used to
escape from the armed robbery uh or
provided the key to to break into the
house not knowing that it was occupied
there's all kinds of people out there
across the country serving life
sentences right now who never killed
attempted to kill or intended to kill
but have been subjected to mandatory
life imprisonment
that I would venture and say the
majority of those individuals uh tend to
be African-American but I haven't
studied it in depth in a while oh my God
yeah but that doesn't matter it doesn't
matter whether you're white black or
Martian it's still wrong for the
legislator the guy who said there's too
many black Pastors in the court when
that was inconvenient is now saying
we've got to think about the racial
aspect here live sentence on an
individual who hasn't killed attempted
to kill or intended to kill and again
this is an issue that would have
a significant impact if it were granted
but we are certainly preserving that
issue secondly with respect to Mr Brian
individually we believe that he is not
eligible for imposition of a mandatory
life sentence pursuant to the eighth
amendment based on the totality of the
circumstances surrounding the offense
his criminal history and other
circumstances which we'll get into
during the sentencing hearing and that
the imposition of a life sentences to Mr
Brian would be unconstitutionally cruel
and disproportionate and we cite the the
relevant Supreme Court authorities as to
that issue
thank you judge
your honor of the legislature has spoken
not only with 1651 which imposes a
mandatory life sentence for felony
murder but also with party to a crime
and conspiracy all of those laws are on
the books for a very important reason
which is responsibility for your actions
and at this point the state is asking
that this court not fly in the face of
the legislature or the statutes that are
on the books especially
1651
based on this particular argument that
somehow Mr Brian is special and outside
the imposition of the law wow thank you
any further word on that motion
on behalf of Greg McMichael we'd like to
join that motion but without any further
argument
it doesn't apply to us really
you're all right
I don't have to object I'm arguing I
guess but the idea that Mr Brian is
asking for special treatment here
it is just wrong contrary to the
argument actually made our position is
that no one in America convicted a
felony murder who didn't kill or attempt
to kill or intend to kill should be
subjected to a mandatory life sentence
that doesn't mean that a court couldn't
impose a mandatory life sentence it
means that the court should
constitutionally have the discretion to
impose the sentence that is appropriate
and to for the legislature to dictate
that these individuals such as Mr Brian
cannot the court cannot consider a
sentence of less than life imprisonment
is cruel and unusual and this practice
needs to stop it's gone on since before
I was born before your honor was born it
was wrong then it's wrong now and
sometimes somewhere it has to stop
secondly as to Mr Brian individually
again it's not suggesting that Mr Brian
is special
it's suggesting that anyone in Mr
Brian's circumstances under the facts of
this case anyone besides Mr Prime is the
same criminal history with the same
background with the same circumstances
that a lie imposition of a mandatory
life sentences would likewise be
disproportionate as to them so this is
not a request for special treatment it
is a request for individualized
sentencing consistent with the Eighth
Amendment well
all right again the Motions filed this
morning I didn't have an opportunity to
review the motion uh having heard the
arguments of council the Court denies
the motion wow Mr Goff next motion
please our third and last uh please
proceed formal written motion there's a
motion to vacate the illegal felony
murder convictions based on Double
Jeopardy uh
and I don't want to be accused of
plagiarizing uh uh an inmate apparently
from the Michigan criminal uh prison
system
um
Mr Cyrus uh sent me was kind enough to
draft a motion for me to file uh and
even went out and found Georgia case law
you're on I have to confess it doesn't
quite reconcile with my memory of all of
the Georgia case law uh but the
argument's pretty good uh Mr Brian was
acquitted of count two felony murder
there is only one felony murder statue
and therefore once you've been acquitted
a felony murder in count two double
jeopardy bars conviction under caps
three four and five this is actually
more interesting they're all different
different ways to commit the same
offense
and we believe that
under the authorities which are not just
State authorities or federal authorities
including sanabary of the U.S 437 U.S
54. yeah the motion came from a prisoner
in Michigan I guess Jeffrey
Jeffrey that's under counts three four
and five
uh independent of that
um
we also have it have an issue with
respect to
the the jury attorney verus if not
guilty as to the Lesser offenses on
count seven
and therefore the verdicts uh the
verdict on count seven is repugnant with
the verdict of the jury after the Lesser
offenses I wouldn't know I don't recall
the court asking the jury to address the
Lesser offenses unless and until this
actually is repugnant he's right about
that
entire defense account seven but
nevertheless the jury did return
verdicts of not guilty the state did not
object the return of those verdicts at
the time and those not guilty verdicts
on those three lesser offenses are
repugnant to the conviction on count
seven and therefore count seven should
be set aside for that reason
and that is my motion
your honor it has been the law in the
state of Georgia and commented and gone
over by the Supreme Court of Georgia
especially as recently as 2015 in Duggar
versus the state
d-u-g-g-e-r versus the state
297 Georgia 1 20. and that's not that
perverted Duggar reality show guy just
so everybody knows of the malice murder
charge but guilty of the felony murder
charge and he claimed Double Jeopardy
because only one person was dead and
they came back not guilty on on the
malice and in this particular case
Duggar they said no that's not how this
works appellant faced a single
prosecution and he received a single
punishment for murdering the victim
that's the quote from this his Double
Jeopardy rights were therefore not
violated
uh in addition he wanted to argue that
these were inconsistent verdicts once
again the Court held that that is not
the case
there was no inconsistency between the
verdicts of guilty on felony murder and
not guilty on malice murder now of
course in this case for Mr Brian he's
claiming well there was a series of
felony murders well the felony murders
are predicated on certain underlying
acts and in this case the jury did find
him not guilty of aggravated assault
with a shotgun and also not guilty of
felony murder based on that aggravated
assault with the shotgun so therefore
their verdict was consistent in that
manner but they did find him guilty of
aggravate assault with the pickup truck
false imprisonment and criminal attempt
at false imprisonment and the felony
murder associated with that those were
the paths to it the state is going to of
course argue that two of those felony
murders will be vacated by operation of
Law and that Mr Brian will only be
sentenced to one of the felony murder
counts and so therefore based on Duggar
as well as numerous other cases and I
believe Duggar was most recently cited
in 2020 by the strong case by the
Georgia Supreme Court very well prepared
there is no legal sound or sound legal
basis in the state of Georgia for a
double jeopardy claim as well as
numeration 22 on page four of defendant
Brian's motion
finding someone not guilty of a lesser
charge doesn't necessarily mean they're
not guilty of a more egregious charge so
the fact that they came back not guilty
on those lesser charges versus the more
heavy charge does not all of a sudden
mean that it's a repugnant and or
inconsistent verdict we ask that you
deny the motion thank you very very
strongly said
you are as Miss donkowski was so kind of
pulling out Duggar is readily
distinguished obviously malice murder is
one crime felony murder is another Mr
akoski is confusing the merger concept
with the double jeopardy issue
and
the in this case these are all felony
murder counts but they're all the same
crime
so that is what distinguishes the Duggar
case and furthermore with respect to the
Lesser offenses that your honor the
jury's verdict on the three lesser
offenses of not guilty indicates that
the jury concluded that an element of
the offense the greater offense was
missing the verdict Marvel pugnant uh
how it's meant to repugnant as a matter
of Law and that therefore the court must
vacate count seven uh asked to Mr Brian
um and that doesn't mean that there
won't be two other felony murder counts
left it may be a academic discussion but
nevertheless we're asking the court to
vacate the conviction under count seven
as Republican with the three misdemeanor
counts and a post sentence on the
misdemeanor can't hold it
again uh as previously indicated the
court received the motion this morning I
did take a look through the motion uh
we've taken look at Duggar in case it's
cited by the state
and the Court denies the motion I
understand you've got one oral motion oh
for three
I appreciate the Court's patience
are making an additional additional
constitutional challenges to Georgia's
76 scheme with respect to the imposition
of the sentence of life without the
possibility of parole
and again as I think prosecutors
suggested many years ago uh a lot of the
sentence in jurisprudence and criminal
law jurisprudence began in death penalty
cases with the theory that death is
different well I think the evolving case
law over the last several decades has
demonstrated that death is really not so
very different after all we assert 8th
and Fifth Amendment challenges to
Georgia's sentencing scheme which
rightly gives judges broad discretion in
determining sentences but with respect
to life without parole that discretion
is effectively unguided as opposed to
the sentencing scheme and death penalty
case for determining the imposition of
the death penalty besides being cruel
the sentencing scheme also violates due
process and that the statute statutes
fail to provide sufficient guidance to
the trial court
and therefore Georgia's sentencing
scheme is hopelessly ambiguous as well
as arbitrary and capricious moreover
without any required findings of fact or
conclusions of law there is nothing for
an appellate court to review to
determine whether a sentence of lack
without parole has been lawfully imposed
furthermore we assert a sixth amendment
challenge
uh well which I would call an apprendy
challenge although it's not actually the
authority uh that any facts increase in
mandatory minimum sentence must be set
which in this case would be I'm not
optimistic about this one either guys a
life sentence that any fact that
increases a mandatory minimum sentence
must be submitted to a jury and found
true Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
I cite
omd-u-s-a-l-l-e-y-n-e 133 S Corp
2151 2013. Blakely the Washington
Blakely the Washington 542 U.S 296
2004. uh your honor the jury acquitted
as to count two and six with count seven
it is impossible to determine what facts
the jury found in this case because the
state elected to pack so much into count
seven you've got parties to the crime
you've got principles to the crime
you've got the McMichaels pickup truck
you've got Mr Brian's pickup truck and
you've got whether it's an intent to
injure or whether it's placing Mr Arbury
in reasonable apprehension of receiving
an injury there's so many different
theories that the jury could have
returned a verdict on that there's no
way to draw any findings meaningful
findings of fact for sentencing purposes
from the verdict that the jury rendered
and therefore under these circumstances
there's nothing here for which the court
could find a jury found basis for
imposing uh the sentence that the state
is seeking in this case thank you let's
take a break lunch is here
Michael we'd like to join that
leadership noted for the record from the
state
[Applause]
of course the state's had a bit of a
disadvantage just having heard the
motion as is the court
however the state's position at this
point in time is this is a legislature
issue the legislature has passed 1651
and it is
a mandatory life sentence the court does
have discretion between life or life
without the possibility of parole
the complaint here it sounds like is
well there's an Eighth Amendment
violation of Fifth Amendment violation a
Sixth Amendment violation because
there's no guidance to the entire thing
is violated as this court is aware the
Supreme Court of Georgia has given
Superior Court judges great deference
because
this court has heard the evidence this
court has seen the demeanor of the
defendants especially in this particular
case the demeanor of Travis McMichael as
he testified
this court has seen the evidence
um from the Witnesses on the stand
and the body cam video of what took
place
so in this case the court is going to be
given and has
received the evidence in this case for
its review to inform it
and its discretion as to whether to
impose a life sentence or a life
sentence without the possibility of
parole
I believe the next step in this process
of course is going to be the state
presenting victim impact and then
argument the defense will present its
argument all of which also informs this
court and allows it to use its broad
discretion and judgment as to whether to
impose a life sentence or a life
sentence without the possibility of
parole right so we ask that you deny
this motion
um thank you judge
final word
with all due respect miss donkowski this
is not a legislative issue the
Constitution is not up for discussion or
negotiation the Constitution is what it
is the fifth sixth and eighth amendments
uh to the United States Constitution or
the federal Provisions that play here in
addition to the parallel provisions of
our Georgia state constitution
legislators or politicians they have to
run for election and they do what they
think they need to do and the job of the
Judiciary as the independent third
branch of government is to put a check
on that action when it violates our
state and federal constitutions so
simply saying that it is a legislative
issue it doesn't address the question
and ultimately it is for our courts to
defend that your honor and the courts
above you are the ultimate guardians of
our state and federal constitutions and
of the individual rights of individuals
and to Simply say or
maybe that wasn't the suggestion but one
could interpret it that way that the
court should simply defer to the
legislature as to what the Constitution
means to the extent that was their
argument it is repugnant to our our
entire system of Criminal Justice I'd
ask the court to Grant the motion
I didn't hear the argument quite that
way where the court has to defer to the
legislature there is a structure in
place with regard to sentencing and this
court intends to adhere to that
structure as established through Georgia
case law uh on that basis the motion is
denied zero for four I understand those
are all preliminary matters and before
the court is the state ready to proceed
with and the way we're going to do it is
I understand it is the state is going to
present any evidence it has in
aggravation as well as a opening
argument the defense is then going to
have an opportunity each individually to
present any evidence in mitigation if
they wish to do so and make argument
with the state then having the rebuttal
that's how I understand we're going to
proceed
from the state here we go
by the way thanks to P weasel and Joe J
freshman everybody signing up via twitch
for the record today is Friday January
7th 2022 the jury returned its verdict
on November 24
2021 that verdict was that Travis
McMichael was found guilty on all nine
counts in the indictment
Greg McMichael was found not guilty of
count one which is malice murder but
guilty on the other
counts two through nine in the
indictment Mr Brian was found guilty
only as to counts three four and five
all felony murder counts and the
underlying felonies corresponding to
those felony murder counts which were
counts seven eight and nine
the court
asked all of us to look into with regard
to Travis McMichael the issue of
potential merger
as to the malice murder charge the state
has reviewed its own indictment and
notes that
it charged Travis McMichael who was
found guilty of count one malice murder
a human being by well did unlawfully
with malice of forethought caused the
death of Ahmad Arbury a human being by
unlawfully chasing him through the
public roadways of the Satilla Shores
neighborhood in pickup trucks and
shooting him with a shotgun contrary to
the laws of said State the good order
peace and dignity thereof
as
the state notes this encompasses two
different actions
unlawfully chasing him through the
public roadways of Satilla Shores which
describes the actions they did in the
pickup trucks and then shooting him with
the shotgun as the court will recall
defense filed a demur to count one
saying this was surplusage and should be
removed the state's argument was that
the state was not going to argue it was
an either or situation and that is not
going to be the state's argument here
the state's argument here is that
factually
the state believes that count eight
false imprisonment factually has been
eaten up
by the way the state charged count one
in this indictment
in other words
count eight and count six would merge
into count one for Travis McMichael on
the malice murder charge because of
unlawfully chasing him meaning Mr Aubry
through the public roadways of the
Satilla Shores neighborhood in pickup
trucks the reason we believe that that
factually would merge is because count
eight is actually the false imprisonment
charge and count eight does say
said accused did chase Mr Aubry with a
Ford F1 pickup truck and a Chevy
Silverado pickup truck through the
public roadways of the Satilla Shores
neighborhood and did confine and detain
Ahmad our break as the court is aware
the statute has nothing to do with
chasing that is descriptive language
factually the statute has to do with
confining and detaining the victim the
fact that the state used up factually
both the chasing in count 8 and the
chasing in count one means both count
six and eight would then merge in to
count one
I believe and I could be wrong but I
will address this that the defense May
argue that counts seven and count nine
would also then merge in to count one
malice murder however the state's
argument is that is not the case
the reason for that is count seven is
the aggravated assault with the pickup
trucks
did make an assault upon the person of
Ahmad Arbury with a Ford F-150 pickup
truck and a Chevy Silverado pickup truck
an object divisor instrument when used
offensively against a person is likely
to result in serious bodily injury
that of course factually can be a number
of different things and what the state
did argue in closing argument was
pulling up a next to somebody startling
them could put them in reasonable
apprehension of receiving serious bodily
injury the state also argued in its
closing argument that Travis McMichael
despite his testimony actually used his
pickup truck to pull in front of Mr
Aubry and cut him off which caused Mr
Aubry on Burford to turn around and run
away so the fact that the jury found
that they used their pickup trucks
objects which used defensively against a
person are likely to result in serious
bodily injury did
create an aggravated assault for Mr
Arbury does not merge into count one
which
was unlawfully chasing him through the
public roadways of Satilla Shores in
pickup trucks they are two separate and
distinct things especially when we have
video evidence of
the McMichaels pulling up next to Mr
Aubry Mr Aubry then running away
that itself right there is an aggravated
assault he was obviously startled he
obviously was trying to get away from
these men they pulled up next to him
reasonable apprehension of her receiving
serious bodily injury
with regard then to count nine count
nine is Criminal attempt to commit the
felony of false imprisonment as the
court will recall the defense also
demurred to that particular charge in
the indictment that particular charge in
the indictment did have an and in it
which as the court knows is an or which
the state explained in its closing
argument to the jury
in this particular
count count nine
it did charge the defendants with
unlawfully chasing or did unlawfully
Chase Ahmad Arbury through the public
roadways of the Satilla Shores
neighborhood in pickup trucks and did
attempt to contain
I'm sorry and did attempt to confine and
detain Ahmad Arbury without legal
Authority on Burford Drive using a Ford
F-150 pickup truck in this particular
instance the state did argue and did
inform the court in the demure response
that it was going to argue and or
because as we know a criminal attempt is
just a substantial step toward
committing that particular felony and as
the court will note count eight took
place on Holmes Drive whereas count nine
was on Burford so they don't have
anything to do with each other they're
two separate incidents at two separate
points in time based on the evidence in
this case so either one could be
considered a substantial step and
because the and in between unlawfully
Chase and did attempt to confine and
detain is really an or for the purposes
of this and once again the state put
that in its response to demur by the
defendants and the court denied the
demur that was found out by the
defendants the state also argued in
closing argument that that was an or
they could find it that he was chased
they could also find that on Burford
they did attempt to confine and detain
him especially with Mr Brian's actions
of trying to run him off the roadway
from his driveway and with Mr
McMichael's actions of cutting him off
at the end of Burford so in this
particular instance especially with the
criminal attempt it does not merge into
malice murder simply because of the
words did unlawfully chase him through
the public roadways contained in count
one I'm not saying that the lawyers for
the defendants aren't good lawyers you
know I don't I don't have the ability to
really evaluate that although the the
weird racial comments from one of them
are just weird as an individual but to a
layperson she seems so much more
competent and well prepared where
there's there's not not even really any
comparison four and five all felony
murder would be vacated by operation of
law
count six which is the aggravated
assault with the shotgun charge would
factually merge into count one
count seven would remain standing and
count seven is a potential sentence of
one to twenty years on the aggravated
assault with the pickup trucks
count eight in the state's opinion would
factually merge then into count one
false imprisonment of course is a one to
ten potential sentence
and count nine criminal attempt cuts
that sentence in half so count nine
criminal attempt to commit false
imprisonment is a potential of one to
five years therefore the minimum
sentence that this court could impose on
Travis McMichael would be life with the
possibility of parole with 15 years and
that Court could suspend probate
um run concurrent with that particular
sentence the maximum and that is what
the state is asking for in this case is
a life without the possibility of parole
the state did file its notice of its
intent to seek life without the
possibility of parole back in 2020 when
this case was first indicted
so the state is seeking life without the
possibility of parole as to count one
counts two through five are vacated by
operation of law count six would merge
into count one leaving then count seven
and nine which would be 25 years we are
asking that that 25 years
um be a 25-year sentence but to be run
concurrent if the court chose to impose
a life without the possibility of parole
sentence and that would be count seven
concurrent with count one
20 years to serve count nine concurrent
with count one consecutive two count
seven
thus making it a total of 25 years
running concurrent with the life without
the possibility of parole sentence on
count one for Travis McMichael and that
is what the state will be requesting and
seeking
with regard to Greg McMichael he was
found not guilty on count one malice
murder he was then found guilty of
counts two three four and five all
felony murder the state is seeking
therefore a life without the possibility
of parole sentence on count two which is
felony murder based on count six which
is the aggravated assault with the
shotgun
counts three four and five would be
vacated by operation of law count six
would merge in to count two
the felony murder
in this particular case that felony
murder only alleges
did cause the death of Ahmad Arbury
based on the aggravated assault with the
shotgun so we do not have the same issue
with language of chasing in count two of
this indictment
this would of course leave count seven
count eight and count nine
um
available for sentencing count seven is
aggravated assault with the pickup
trucks that's a potential one to twenty
year sentence count eight
false imprisonment on homes drive a one
to ten year sentence count nine criminal
attempt to commit false imprisonment a
one to five year sentence so the minimum
Greg McMichael is looking at is life
with the possibility of parole and 35
years
that 35 years can be run concurrent it
can be probated it can be suspended the
maximum Mr McMichael is looking at Mr
Greg McMichael is looking at is Count
two the state is going to be asking for
life without the possibility of parole
counts three four and five are vacated
by operation of law account six would
merge into that life without the
possibility of parole sentence and the
additional 35 years to be run concurrent
consecutive meaning count seven
concurrent with count two twenty years
to serve count eight
concurrent to count two consecutive to
count seven and count nine the five
years
to serve concurrent with count two
consecutive two count eight resulting in
a 35-year sentence to be run
concurrently with the life without the
possibility of parole sentence on count
two
with regards is the if a lawyer can say
is the point of the 35 years in addition
to life that if somehow the life is
vacated they've still got 35 years is
that the point
assault with the pickup truck false
imprisonment and criminal attempt at
false imprisonment
the state is looking at a life sentence
about three counts four and five would
be vacated by operation of law he was
found not guilty on count six therefore
count seven the aggregate assault with
the pickup truck would merge into count
three because count three is the felony
murder based upon count
seven
so count seven would merge into count
three count eight false imprisonment
potential one to ten year sentence and
count nine a potential
five one to five year sentence therefore
the minimum Mr Brian is looking at is a
life with the possibility of pearl
sentence plus an additional 15 years
which once again can be run concurrent
it could be run consecutive it could be
probated and or suspended in this
particular case the state is going to
make a recommendation for Mr Brian of
life with the possibility of parole on
count three with 15 years to serve
consecutively on probation and that is
going to be our recommendation for Mr
Brian interesting your honor at this
time the state will go ahead and present
its victim impact evidence for the Fort
Court's consideration and then once
that's through we will make our argument
moving right along
time we're going to present Mr Marcus
Arbury
welcome everybody this is the sentencing
if you're just joining us I do want to
make a point before we get into the
victim impact statements and not to
imply that this would go any other way
but I do want to make sure that those
that are addressing the court address
the court uh as opposed to anybody else
in the gallery so let's go ahead and
proceed
and really thanks to everybody who's
been supporting the stream thanks to
Johnny K Tyler
right
it's all right time for me and my family
you know something that I just
doesn't sit right with me at this time
the man who killed my son has
sitting in this courtroom
every single day
next to his father
I'll never get that chance
the six next to my son Elba again
not at a general General table
not at a Holiday
and not at a win
he'll never get to hell
I pray
that no one in this courtroom ever
has to do what we had
did
that buried their child
there's no word
for that because no world knows
that much pain
not only did they let my son and brought
daylight but they killed him while he
was doing what he
loved
than anything
running
that's when he felt
most alive
most free
and they
took all of that from him
when I when I
close my eyes I see his execution in my
mind
over and over
I'll see that for the rest of my life
when I became a father
my life became bigger than me
it became about my family
about
protecting him
protecting my boy
I know in my head that
there's nothing I could have done that
day
to have saved my son
to have protect him from that evil and
Hate
but my heart is broken
and always will be broken
because on my worst day
or our lives wasn't there
if I could I had trade places where
tomorrow
in a heartbeat
but I can't
so I'm standing here
today to do what I
he can
and there's a fight for him
fight for his memories his legacy
and to tell you who to
who he was
because that's the one thing you didn't
hear in this courtroom
and more
than anything else
you should
know who my boy was
we love our son and we will never have
him with us to celebrate anything
Thanksgiving Christmas
for his birthday
his kill should spend the rest of their
lives thinking about what they did
and what they took from us
and they should do
it from behind bars
because me and my family we got to live
with his death the rest of our life
we'll never see a mod again
tilapia they should stay behind them
balls the rest of their life because
they didn't give him a chance
thank the court
thank y'all for what y'all did our
family stuff now thank you
I get all glory to God thank y'all
thank you strawberry wow
foreign
good morning
my name is Jasmine Aubry
Ahmad is my brother and I would like to
tell you a little about him
Ahmad had dark skin that glistened in
the sunlight like gold
he had thick curly hair
and he would often like to twist it
I might had a broad nose
and the color of his eyes was real with
melanin
he was tall with an athletic build
he enjoyed running and had an
appreciation for being outdoors
foreign
these are the qualities that made these
men assume that Ahmad was a dangerous
criminal and chased him with gone strong
to me those qualities reflected a young
man full of life and energy
who look like me and the people I love
Ahmad was funny
he told jokes to lie in the mood because
he was a positive thinker
I might had a big personality and never
missed the opportunity to let it shine
that was taken from him in the instance
of violence
he was robbed of his life Pleasures big
and small
he would never be able to fulfill his
professional dreams
know he be able to start a family or
even be a part of my daughter's life
foreign
has devastated me and my family
so I'm asking that the man that killed
him be given the maximum sentence
available to the court
thank you
and guys some of the behavior in the
chat is disgusting and we're Banning
everybody we're you're all getting
banned
foreign
good morning good morning
oh I want to First speak directly to my
son
if I please
this verdict
doesn't bring you back
but it does help bring closure
to this very difficult chapter of my
life
I made a promise to you
today I laid you to rest
I told you I love you
and someday
somehow
I would get you justice
son I love you
as much today
as I did today that you were born
raising you
what's the honor of my life
and I'm very proud of you
your honor
these men
have chose to lie
and attack my son
and his surviving family
they each have no remorse
and do not deserve any leniency
this wasn't a case
of mistaken identity
all right
mistaken fact
they chose they chose to Target my son
because they didn't want him and their
community
they chose to treat him differently
than other people who frequently visited
their community
and when they couldn't
sufficiently scare him
or intimidate him they killed him
my youngest son
he was born on Mother's Day
of 1994.
he had a smile so bright it lit up a
room
he was a greedy baby
that seemed like he was always searching
for something to stick into his mouth
he was always a loving baby who's who
seemed
to never Tire of hugs cuddling
and kisses
he loved
he loved he never hesitated to tell me
his sister Jasmine and his brother
Marcus that he loved us
and your honor we loved him back
he was messy
he sometimes refused to wear socks
I take good care of his good clothing
I wish he would have cut
and cleans his toenails before he went
out for that jock that day
I guess he would have if he knew he
would be murdered
my family is going to miss the mod
we're going to miss his jokes
his impersonations
his warm smile
these men
deserve the maximum sentence
for the crimes
Ahmad never said a word to them
he never threatened them
he just wanted to be left alone
they were fully they were fully
committed to their crimes
let them be full let them be fully
committed
for the consequences
your honor I'm standing here for you as
the mother of Ahmad Aubry
asking you to please
give all three defendants
who are responsible for the death of my
son
the maximum punishment in this court
which I do believe is life Behind Bars
without the possible
chance for parole thank you
thank you
any additional evidence and aggravation
from the state no more additional
evidence
now moving on to the argument on
sentencing from the prosecutors
your honor the state is seeking life
without the possibility of parole for
the McMichaels based primarily on the
evidence presented in this case state is
not going to go through all of that
evidence just a few very important items
first off there was a demonstrated
pattern of vigilanteism by Greg and
Travis McMichael first off we have our
July 13
2019 9-1-1 call after both of them went
with guns to confront a homeless man who
was living under the bridge who they
suspected
must have been committing all of these
crimes
of course all of these crimes included
a lot of reports to 9-1-1 about
suspicious persons and as we heard from
the witness stand and defense Witnesses
a couple of unlocked cars with things
stolen out of them by people outside the
neighborhood
and then we have February 11 2020.
yes Ahmad went inside
of the open unsecured construction site
that particular day
but Travis McMichael
went home
got his father
they both got their guns and then they
went back down
to that construction site we know that
because we heard the 9-1-1 call and he
says I'm sitting outside the
construction site
he talks about seeing somebody inside
with a flashlight
the horrible part as we know from Brooke
Perez who testified for the defendants
that her husband had gotten a call from
Larry English and he'd gone over there
with his handgun
we also know that the two men went
inside with their handguns
it's a miracle they didn't shoot each
other
and no one had called the police
Travis is outside in the pickup truck
finally calling the police he stays on
for about four minutes and then
officer Ash appears
that didn't teach anybody here a lesson
at all
Brooke Perez was trying to tell them no
my husband's over there with a gun you
know be careful go in there but Greg
McMichael took off according to Travis's
statement down the street and went right
into that house
so we've got July 2019 February 11 2020.
not calling 9-1-1 first not staying home
but
wanting to seek out
in a vigilante manner a confrontation
with people that they suspect
might be doing something that they
themselves up until January 1st of 2020
had not been the victim of
in all cases they took Firearms with
them did not stay home did not allow the
police to do their job but instead
as on February 11th Greg Michael went in
and started searching the house himself
we all know that how that could have
turned out terribly for him for anyone
in there and for Diego Perez
all the decisions they made
that led up to the death of Ahmad Arbury
there were so many opportunities to stop
to think
and here's the real problem
Greg McMichael was former law
enforcement as they pointed out
repeatedly
and Travis McMichael had served in the
Marines I'm not the Marines the Coast
Guard as they pointed out repeatedly
right
so here we have some men who should have
known better
should have known better
vigilantism always goes wrong
you wait for the professionals to show
up
the professionals who are in marked cars
the professionals who are in uniforms
the professionals who are going to do it
right because they have something to
lose
the professionals with body cams right
the professionals such as officer rash
who just would have stopped Mr Arbury
and said hey I'm going to put you on the
phone with Larry English so Leary
English can tell you to please not to
come back
and they should have known that
they had Alternatives they had choices
but instead Travis McMichael
who stated he was putting his son
Everett down for a nap
who stated that his father had all these
medical and health problems
didn't say no Dad I'm putting Everett
down no Dad you need to stay here he
grabbed his shotgun
which he stated was propped up in a
corner in that house
to go with his father
and Gregory Michael was willing to get
into that pickup truck and sit in a
child's seat
to go chase after Mr Aubry
Greg McMichael
attempted to control the narrative from
the get-go at the scene
his statements were all about
how they were Justified how it was
self-defense how Mr Aubry attacked his
son
when the unknown man came up to Greg
McMichael at the scene because of course
the police hadn't put Mr McMichael
anywhere told him not to talk to anybody
he was running around the scene talking
to everybody
and when talking to this Unknown man who
walked up to give him water he basically
said no this guy's an [ __ ] he is 20
feet from Mr arbory's body
referring to Mr Aubry as an [ __ ]
there's been no remorse shown
and certainly no empathy from either man
because empathy would have said hey how
must this look to this person that we're
chasing
are we terrifying this person are we
scaring them
no empathy for the trapped and terrified
Ahmad arbory
there was thoughtlessness as to the
consequences
thoughtlessness as to the alternatives
there was vigilanteism
and because of that we are asking for
Travis McMichael and Greg McMichael to
be sentenced to life with the
possibility of parole
Travis McMichael on count one malice
murder Greg McMichael I'm felony murder
count two
with the prior sentences or the
underlying charges to run concurrent
consecutive per the state's prior
statement
the state is going to guess that the
defense will probably say that these men
serve their country they served the
community
Travis in the Coast Guard to be
aggravating Michael not mitigating
District Attorney's office but we all
know it is not the 99 things you do
right not the 99 Good Deeds that you do
but when you take another person's life
it can't be undone it can't be taken
back there is no do-over
it's final and that means caution must
prevail
thoughtfulness empathy and insight must
prevail
not vigilanteism
with regard to Mr Brian
his actions speak for themselves he
contributed to the death of Ahmad Arbury
in a significant way
the court is familiar with his actions
the court is familiar with his
statements with his level of cooperation
with agent Seacrest afterwards
and given his actions and statements in
this case the state is asking for a life
with the possibility of parole sentence
and that would be on count three with 15
years consecutive on probation for Mr
Brian
thank you your honor
there is the prosecutions argument yeah
Mr Reuben
your honor for 150 years
judges
in cases in which defendants were
convicted of murder
we're authorized to impose a life
sentence that was the only sentence
available
in 2009 the legislature expanded the
judge's discretion
and now allows a judge to impose both a
life sentence with the possibility of
parole and a life sentence without the
possibility of parole and gives
absolutely as Mr Goff pointed out no
guidance to the court
as to what factors to take into account
when differentiating between people
convicted of murder
but I know this court this your honor
has been on the bench long enough in his
tried a number of cases including murder
cases in which you've had to make those
decisions and you've had to
differentiate between defendants and be
consistent in your
rulings in your sentencing probably the
hardest thing any court has to do which
is to sentence a person
to time in prison
in this case
in which the state is seeking the
harshest possible sentence
allowable under the law
we're asking the court to reserve the
harshest possible sentence under the law
for those who deserve it for the worst
of the worst
when the facts of the crime show a
darkness of soul
a person so depraved and heinous has to
shock the conscience by their actions I
don't know or where the offender is such
a danger as evidenced by his past
conduct
or by his actions post-defense isn't
that these guys such that Rehabilitation
is remote or impossible those are the
offenders who deserve the harshest
possible punishment under the law those
are the offenders
who people would argue deserve to spend
the rest of their lives
in prison
neither of those scenarios
encompasses Travis McMichael or the
conduct for which he was convicted
and like Miss donikoski I want to spend
just a couple minutes
reviewing the conduct for which he was
convicted because I agree with something
she said maybe for the first time in
this trial
when Travis McMichael woke up on that
Sunday morning
with his son Everett in his house
his goal was not to go out and kill
somebody
his goal was to play with his kid that
doesn't seem relevant to the facts of
the charges though possibly with Greg
and his mom Lee and sister Lindsay his
goal was not to commit a crime that day
or kill somebody that day his goal was
to have a family afternoon and when he
was putting a son down
at one o'clock or so in the afternoon
he was doing what every single person
wants to and should be doing which is
taking care
of their toddler son
when he got in the truck at his father's
behest
to find out who that person was
sprinting down the road
his goal still was not to commit a crime
his goal still was not to hurt that
person to merely investigate to find out
what was that guy doing
back at the house where Matt albenzi was
motioning
and then four minutes later Mr arbory's
dead
Mr McMichael's covered in blood
and we have what we have here and what
the jury heard and he was convicted the
jury found that his actions
constituted malice murder felony murder
and the underlying felonies
but this is not a case in which he just
targeted someone recklessly targeted
someone without knowledge misidentified
someone he knew a mod Aubry he had
encountered him previously
and he had known about the fears that
the neighbors felt
at Mr aubry's continued presence I'm not
going to retry the case the jury found
that those facts did not add up to
probable cause
and did not justify Mr McMichael's
actions but he didn't just go out and
shoot Mr Aubry he only fired the shots
the Fatal shots
when Mr Aubry came at him and grabbed
the gun as Dr Donahue demonstrated
these were not
and as Reckless as those acts may have
been
as Miss donikoski point out as
thoughtless as they may have been
they are not evidence
of a soul so blackened as to deserve to
spend the rest of his life in prison
this was not a planned murder this was
not a murder involving torture
it was a fight over a gun that resulted
in Mr aubry's death and for that
the jury found Mr McMichael guilty
the state
contends
that 99 good acts don't overcome one bad
act and of course legally that's true Mr
McMichael is now a convicted felon
but 99 good acts
do weigh in this Court's consideration
do factor into what choice
this court is going to make when
sentencing Mr McMichael
to either spend the rest of his life
Behind Bars
or
give him the possibility of redemption
and those Acts
those 99 good acts the court heard about
those in the bond hearing
the court heard that during his time as
a lifeguard
at a camp for kids who are um
who have uh family members with terminal
illnesses
that Travis McMichael actually saved a
life of a boy who was drowning in the
pool
the court heard
that Mr McMichael while serving in the
Coast Guard
literally saved the lives of family
members who were on a boat that was
taking on water
the court heard that Mr McMichael saved
the crew of a coast guard vessel while
serving in the Coast Guard
the court heard of the letters of
commendation
given to Mr McMichael by his superiors
for various Acts
that the superior said show Superior
dedication
selfless devotion to duty and
consideration of others
and adherence to our core values honor
respect and Devotion to duty
they don't excuse anything that happened
on February 23rd but when the court is
weighing in the scales of Justice what
people deserve to spend their lives
and then die in prison
versus those people who deserve to be
punished but then hold out hope for
Redemption
those are the acts the court should
consider
Mr McMichael was a devoted father to
Everett
he had Everett 50 percent of the time
shared custody with Everett's mom
and in fact
at early on was shown to be the more
reliable parent
although I know that changed over time
with his mom stepping up
he was a friend to many people who are
now too scared to come to court and
speak on his behalf
as the court knows from the testimony it
heard in trial and at the bond hearing
he was always a hard worker
always had a job
never laid around
letting other people support him always
paid taxes always supported his
community in a variety of ways
the discovery that we received is
replete with FBI and gbi interviews of
people in his community people who told
law enforcement officials of the times
Mr McMichael helped them when they were
having problems when it's weird because
these really don't sound like mitigating
circumstances for this Ox were pulled
off from storms and Mr McMichael was out
there finding those things and bringing
them back to the owners or helping other
people in the community uh just as he
thought he was doing
on February 23rd
actions that in hindsight turned out to
be thoughtless as Miss donikoski said
we're Reckless but we're not evidence of
an abandoned and malignant heart
nothing in Travis McMichael's life
suggests that he's a danger to society
now it's crazy because like not being
lazy is supposed to mean you get a
lesser sentence when you killed someone
and are found guilty I just I mean I
understand the concept of mitigating
circumstances but you'd think they'd be
mitigating in this in the crime in me
right now
do we still
need want
a person like Travis McMichael Behind
Bars
there's nothing in his post-offense
conduct that shows that he's either
mentally unstable or a sociopath
he cooperated fully with police he told
the police everything he knew to tell
them
because he thought he was doing the
right thing even if that thing turned
out not to be right
he and Greg McMichael thought they were
helping their community
they thought they were helping the
police catch someone who inexplicably
had been in a house and we still don't
know what he was doing in the house
on four or five different occasions
he never fled he never tried to obstruct
the investigation
when he talked to his neighbors about
what happened he always expressed
remorse and disbelief
if life without parole is reserved for
the worst of offenders those who are so
scary so unpredictable and so likely to
pose a threat in the future
then it is not appropriate for someone
like Travis McMichael
the only purpose
of a life without parole sentence your
honor is vengeance
it's retribution
and the urge to seek vengeance is strong
and understandable in the family
Lord knows if I was in their position I
would be seeking the same thing
but vengeance is not the foundation of
our sentencing
in our Criminal Justice System
Redemption is
Redemption is the belief that a person
can learn can grow and still contribute
after punishment
it is pointless to continue to punish a
person who has undergone changes in
character that distance him from the
person who committed the crime decades
previously
decades
Travis McMichael
35 years old now should have the
opportunity to show that he's grown
to show that he's changed and the parole
board
years from now
is in the best position to determine
whether he should remain Behind Bars
or can serve a useful purpose to society
who knows where we will be as a society
in 30 years why make a decision today
that impacts so many people
long after we're gone long after you and
I are retired hopefully good good
comment here from defense attorney
Graham Henry helping us understand
mitigating circumstances with this
decision
three decades hence
why make a decision today that snuffs
out all possibility of growth of
redemption in Travis McMichael
compassion for Travis McMichael and the
humility to admit that we don't know
what's going to happen in the future
doesn't diminish The Compassion that we
feel for Ahmad aubry's family
their loss is real and understandable
and their desire
for the maximum punishment is real and
understandable
but again that's why we have judges
imposing sentence and not the families
of the victim
because there are a lot of factors this
court takes into consideration
deterrence
Rehabilitation retribution those are all
valid factors
but the only thing an l-wop sentence
serves is retribution
wouldn't it be healing for Mr aubry's
family for Travis McMichael to a tone
to be able to express the remorse that's
in his heart without the Specter of a
federal trial hanging over his head
we've heard several times today
that he's shown No Remorse but this
court knows that no lawyer would allow
Mr McMichael to say anything about his
feelings towards the family while there
were two pending murder trials against
him
when the Witnesses were interviewed by
law enforcement about
Mr McMichael's conversations with them
to a person they said that he showed
remorse that he never wanted to kill
somebody
he was merely trying to detain Mr Aubry
for the police
it is disingenuous
and unfair to express Mr McMichael to
expect Mr McMichael to express remorse
with yet another trial
beginning in three weeks
where everything he says
can be used by the federal government
against him
wouldn't it be powerful though for
Travis McMichael to look deep into
himself and explore with the public
with his son Everett why he did what he
did
and in fact become a Force for good
while in prison and out instead of one
more
old man
Behind Bars costing taxpayers fifty
thousand dollars a year or more in 30
years
wouldn't it be healing
to Society for someone like Travis
McMichael to be free
to help heal the wounds that
are certainly present in this country
due to decades and decades and Decades
of discrimination of racism
wounds that were just now beginning to
try to heal
judge you can send a message
four minutes of conduct
does not erase a life well lived
it can after punishment there is
opportunity you could do pretty bad
things in four minutes
an opportunity that Travis can either
take advantage of
and prove himself worthy or not and that
the parole board can then determine
whether he should be released from
prison
we are not asking you to do anything
your honor but to agree that we don't
know today
what the future holds
we're asking you to sentence him to life
with the possibility
of parole if it's earned
agree with the state I believe
count seven and count nine do merge
I believe the language of chasing
Mr Aubry through the Satilla Shores
neighborhood that is
that is stated in count one and also
stated in counts uh seven and nine
were used up worse assumed subsumed
and would be therefore would effectuate
a merger of those crimes
in either event this court has wide
discretion in how it Fashions so I see
confusion in the chat the main
disagreement this is with respect to
Travis McMichael prosecution wants life
in prison without parole plus I think it
was 35 years or some number
he's asking for the possibility of pearl
McMichael
but for the Arbury family and what
Travis Michael can prove himself worthy
of in the future thank you honor
thank you
all right I think we're probably a good
breaking Point Let's go ahead and take a
break let everybody get some lunch we
will plan on reconvening at uh one
o'clock it's just before 12 o'clock now
at that time thank you
all right very very good they are going
to be going into a break we are in the
middle of the sentencing of the three
men convicted in the killing of Ahmad
Arbury uh expecting this to conclude my
guess is if each of the other two
defense attorneys takes even a full half
hour we've got another hour rebuttal
from the state and then I don't know if
they will immediately then uh announce
the sentence but we're we're getting
very very close uh super chats are
coming in Isaac asking David sir where
are the calzones by the way how are the
calzones they are going to lunch now
they are going to lunch now thank you to
everybody who has joined I I have to
thank so many people who are supporting
today's stream thank you to Don Hamilton
who just signed up on my website
uh don actually getting two memberships
but then canceling a different one
something very very confusing with Don's
memberships but Don is number 26 today
also thanks to everybody who's been
supporting on Twitch that includes Deb
Andrew Daniel Braithwaite Johnny K Tyler
and Kinsey a few of these I already
tacked up there but that does now put us
at 28. a lot of different arguments
being made here uh of in the chat about
uh perspectives on mitigating and
aggravating circumstances etc etc and we
will ultimately see uh what the judge
decides and all of it so they are on
lunch I am going to take lunch as well
we are going to keep the stream going
and then we are going to be back I do
actually have a calzone waiting for me
by the way how are the calzones and
we're all going to be back and we will
continue and we believe we believe that
we are going to get to this uh by the
end of the day stand by everybody I will
be back with you
[Music]
this is
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
president
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
in that area
[Music]
[Music]
is right here
[Music]
you're having her for like a strong
picture
[Music]
foreign
look at your jacket list
Angela the bravest of all
you got a good shot of that I mean I
took it in the face so hopefully
hopefully it was worth it try to do like
a slow move
I turned down yeah Jeremy may have the I
actually
I mean like I don't know
foreign
all right welcome back everybody we are
a close to the end of the break here in
the sentencing of the three men
convicted of killing Ahmad Arbury I am
thrilled to have all of you
with me here and we are going to
um listen to some of your thoughts some
of your questions and and different
things super chats will be up on screen
as people send them let me see if I
missed any recently it doesn't look like
it
uh okay good
um had a uh Beautiful Exchange with our
YouTube rep recently he believes that
news is back and indeed yesterday was
our biggest Day on YouTube dating all
the way back to January 18th of 2021 and
you know we've been talking about the
framing has been usually interest in
midterm elections increases interest in
politics in general around June of a
midterm year but this year we were
thinking it might be more like May or
even April we are starting to see some
early indicators that this for better or
worse and I won't tell you which which
it is because I don't know
for better or worse this may be the
earliest starting midterm season
um maybe maybe of all time uh just an
incredible Resurgence and interest in
what is going on in the political system
so let's let's get back into it I do
want to thank rare Beastie for the
twitch Prime subscription while I was
away You're number 29 today also very
very warm welcome to Lynn stetler who
signed up on my website with the coupon
code wow22 and Hannah Flack who signed
up on my website with the coupon code
Obama
you are new members 30 and 31.
30 and 31 today very much appreciate
that just to reorient ourselves let's go
back and watch a little bit more of the
verdict from November 24th 2021 remember
the verdict was in November today is
sentencing we have heard Victim Impact
statements we've heard the case from the
prosecution we've heard four motions
from the defense denied next we have the
um uh mitigating statement from two of
the three defendants and then the state
gets to make its final rebuttal and then
we will have a sentence okay let's take
a look this was sentencing
so the first guilty verdict against uh
this I what is this guy's name I just
can't Gregory McMichael has been read
ing
foreign
I ask that there'd be no outbursts in
the court and I expect as much from the
gallery please respect the courts
a desire for this as we move oh sorry
guys I'm an idiot that's Roddy Brian
that that was yeah I apologize that
that's Rowdy Brian I said I said
completely the wrong name I continue to
just be really struggling to identify
these defendants this is Travis
McMichael that I know I feel like you
need to make a comment or otherwise
demonstrate with respect to the verdict
I do ask that you step out of the
courtroom now
count two felony murder we the jury find
the defendant Travis McMichael guilty
count three felony murder we the jury
find the defendant Travis McMichael
guilty
count four felony murder we the jury
find the defendant Travis McMichael
guilty
count five felony murder we the jury
find the defendant Travis McMichael
guilty
count six aggravated assault we the jury
find the defendant Travis McMichael
guilty
count seven aggravated assault we the
jury find the defendant Travis McMichael
guilty
count eight false imprisonment we the
jury find the defendant Travis McMichael
guilty count nine criminal attempt to
commit a felony we the jury find the
defendant Travis McMichael guilty
dated this 24th day of November 2021
signed by the fourth person
I'll see
as to Gregory McMichael
in the superior court of Glenn County
the state of Georgia versus Greg
McMichael case number cr0 I'm sorry two
zero zero zero four three three
verdict form count one malice murder
we the jury find the defendant Greg
McMichael not guilty
count two felony murder we the jury find
the defendant Greg McMichael guilty
count three felony murder we the jury
find the defendant Greg McMichael guilty
count four felony murder
we the jury find the defendant Greg
McMichael guilty
count five felony murder we the jury
find the defendant Greg McMichael guilty
count six aggravated assault
we the jury find the defendant Greg
McMichael guilty
count seven aggravated assault we the
jury find the defendant Greg McMichael
guilty
count eight false imprisonment we the
jury find the defendant Greg McMichael
guilty
count nine criminal attempt to commit a
felony we the jury find the defendant
Greg McMichael guilty this 24th day of
November 2021 signed by the 4th
as to William R Bryan
in the superior court of Glenn County
state of Georgia the state of Georgia
versus William R Bryan case number
cr2000433 jury verdict 4.
count one malice murder we the jury find
the defendant William R Bryan not guilty
count two felony murder we the jury find
the defendant William R Bryan not guilty
count three felony murder
we the jury find the defendant William R
Bryan guilty
count four felony murder we the jury
find the defendant William R Bryan
guilty
count five felony murder we the jury
find the defendant William R Bryan
guilty count six
aggravated assault we the jury find the
defendant William R Bryan not guilty
count seven aggravated assault we the
jury find the defendant William R Bryan
guilty
count eight
false imprisonment
we the jury find the defendant William R
Bryan guilty
count nine criminal attempt to commit a
felony
we the jury find the defendant William R
Bryan guilty
signed this 24th day of November by the
four person so those were the verdicts
back on November 24th
um 2021 and now guys in the in the chat
guys and gals guys gals and non-binary
Pals to quote uh to quote Kenji correct
me if I'm wrong my general understanding
of what the prosecution has asked for is
that for Travis McMichael the younger of
the two
um you know the the murder family
whatever you want to call them Travis
McMichael they've asked for
what they're calling elwop life in
prison without parole plus a bunch of
years uh consecutive
for the dad they've asked for life in
prison with the possibility of parole
plus a bunch of years and then for the
neighbor
they've asked for 15 years is that I'm
trying I'm now thinking back because
we've already watched a bunch of of
hours of this today is that more or less
is that more or less what they've asked
for please keep me honest here
nobody knows oh that's too bad okay
um
well
that's that's a shame
um
all right anyway that's by General
understanding and they're going to be
back any moment how much is left we
don't really know it could be about 45
minutes and then I don't know if
immediately
uh I don't know if immediately the judge
will render the sentence uh the neighbor
life with pearl oh the neighbor was life
with pearl okay okay thank you thank you
very good all right I want to say thanks
to Jonathan Kennedy Jonathan just signed
up on my website joinpakman.com using
the coupon code Obama
if you have any comment or prediction or
anything
um you can send a Super Chat it'll show
up up over there via YouTube you can
include a message with your Twitch Prime
subsimby art just grab the twitch Prime
subscription so did user who says
redubbed love the show thank you you are
new uh member number 34. also want to
say thanks to JD straight shot who just
gifted a subscription to one lucky
viewer on Twitch putting us at 35 are we
in the middle of a hype train I think we
are hold on let me see what's going on
here yeah level one complete okay wow
all right we're on level two over on
Twitch
level two is one of the higher levels
relative to one anyway they should be
back in 10 minutes for people asking
when they will be back uh we're keeping
an eye on a number of different channels
and different things they've been gone
for
how long have they been gone they've
been gone for
about 52 minutes which suggests they
should be back very very soon thanks to
Jay tandoway for gifting five
subscriptions on Twitch I really
appreciate that that uh that's really
really great let's listen to a few
voicemails as people have been calling
in with commentary about uh what what
has taken place today let me go over to
my voicemail
area
um let's see what we got here
hey David this is uh Steve calling from
Vancouver BC a long time member here uh
usually yeah so uh I watched the shows
and sometimes I'll go on YouTube to
watch like a clip and then I know it's
at the end and there's ads and uh it's
just interesting to know a little more
about you
um on this that you're wearing these
Teddy Stratford shirts for something
that I didn't know but um yeah sometimes
it's uh I just see an ad but uh usually
yeah I'll just watch the full show with
no rest but just an interesting
um observation that's true no in the ad
for Teddy Stratford I am wearing a Teddy
Stratford shirt that is 100 accurate
um here's another voicemail
hey David
um what are your recommendations in
terms of pants
specifically non-gene like uh khakis or
slacks or pants in general what are your
go-to brands
um something that's like comfortable
somewhat affordable maybe like under
fifty dollars
for for one pant one now that's an
interesting thing when this gentleman
says under fifty dollars for one pant
does that mean it's fifty dollars per
leg so the pair of pants is a hundred
dollars or do they mean under fifty
dollars for both legs
that's an interesting question it's sort
of like is a hot dog a sandwich that's
that I I don't that's a really really
interesting question listen I don't have
any specific
I don't have any uh I don't have any
specific brands or anything my one thing
is the following these are my two bits
of advice I I am very hesitant to give
fashion advice I mean look at what I'm
wearing but there's two things I want to
say if you're wearing a button-down
shirt
and the top button is unbuttoned such
that the undershirt is visible make sure
you're wearing a v-neck you don't want a
crew neck undershirt visible
as like a little it's almost like a uh
like a Catholic collar you know you
don't wear a v-neck undershirt if you're
wearing an unbuttoned button-down shirt
and then when it comes to pants no more
pleated pants you know pleats it's all
those lines that kind of point to the
crotch it's an old school thing pleated
pants are out don't got get so whether
you're going with a Chino or a dress
pant or whatever stay away from those
pleats it's a very very old-fashioned
look which I think we're we're Beyond
right now so I hope I will not be judged
negatively
Bay photo says get a poll going on what
the sentence will be it's just so tough
because there's three different people
and it's hard to get a poll going but
we're maybe we will do that if the
moderators want to take the lead on that
that would be fine that would be fine
David a week or two ago Dr racanello
suggested it's time to lift the strict
restriction since the virus is low risk
for the vaxxed what are your thoughts I
we are trying to get Dr rack and yellow
back on the program I want to talk to
him about that personally let me see if
it's on the calendar he's going yeah
he's going to be back in about 12 days
and I will ask him and at that point
we'll have had more time for Omicron to
kind of burn through and so we'll see
what he's thinking at the time but I'll
I want to ask him personally before I
say more about that I want to say thank
you to relevant Millennial and D4 Rey
for the twitch Prime subscriptions
putting us at 42 today very much
appreciate that guys
um
other no no other super chats let's go
to a couple of other
voicemails hi David so I used to think
that Joe Biden's January 6th speech was
a really solid speech and it is now the
next day
um because I thought it was a good
speech I tried to listen to it uh again
and watch it again and read the
transcript yeah and there's a part about
halfway through where I was just so
disgusted with the speech that I had to
just stop watching it and this was the
bipartisanship ship stuff
why are they so obsessed with
bipartisanship it makes no sense to me
this is a democracy you vote for the
people you want and whoever is the
majority of those wins it shouldn't
matter what party there are it shouldn't
be bipartisan it should be tripartisan
it should be quadrupartisan it should be
pentapartisan it I I was just so
disgusted to hear that and this is all
we get from the Democrats yeah I mean to
some degree it's this thing of like how
can you find common ground with lunatics
it's it's certainly a fair question I
agree David Bradley Austin tomorrow this
is not Bradley Austin this is Troy York
calling again
um well Democrats just keep doing this
for over a year we keep hearing about
January 6th January 6th it's it's just
he's so mushed mouth it's so difficult
to understand hey David I called
yesterday again my question was why do
people on the right every time you
criticize that Chris has a Republican or
somebody on the right
they automatically see it as an
endorsement of people on the left or the
Democrats right
um like
I made a criticism of Joe manchin last
night and the first thing my aunt does
is snaps and brings up and they want
Nancy Quincy you know
what the hell does it have to do with
Nancy Pelosi we would I'm I'm mentioned
something about Joe Manson I made a
statement of fact about Joe manchin wow
this guy's shot out of a cannon but he's
completely right absolutely and
completely right
um I want to say thanks to Paulie Esther
helicomatic as well for the twitch Prime
subscriptions number 43 and 44 and I
want to invite you consider this a
personal invitation to re-up your Twitch
Prime subscription if you are watching
on Twitch today
um Bay photo says anyone else feel
Biden's speech yesterday would have been
more effective a year ago I would have
loved to see the fire and energy a year
ago sure but I still think it was a very
very good speech
other voicemails coming in
let's see what we've got here hey David
Sean from Ohio I've been a while since
I've called you I'm asking one very
specific question at what point do we as
Americans accept that insurance can deny
somebody coverage
for a covid cost if they weren't
vaccinated when they were offered a free
vaccine when they had the opportunity to
get the free vaccine and they did not
have a health or religious reason why
they didn't get the vaccine what do you
think about that so listen I really
don't have a moral problem with saying
hey you know what if there's no valid
reason for you not to get a vaccine if
you have a problem as a result then we
get to deny you coverage I don't have a
problem with it morally I have two
problems with it though I have a problem
with it logistically and I'm going to
give you guys an example
if you get
a complication from covid against which
you were unvaccinated by choice
it is very difficult to determine
whether it's really a complication from
covid or if it's an issue you would have
had anyway because covet is so
wide-ranging in terms of the types of
complications it can cause
uh how can you say for sure well we're
not going to cover we're not going to
cover this asthma
because it might have been a result of
Cove that's really difficult and number
two we don't apply this anywhere else we
don't deny smokers treatment for lung
cancer we don't deny obese people
treatment for
um uh heart attacks so I think there's
also a problem where if you open this
door
so it's not a moral question for me it's
really a more of a logistical question
uh but it's I mean but it's it's a
question that is being asked a ton it's
being asked a ton
uh it's murky territory take a hike with
Daniel has grabbed a twitch Prime
subscription and his new member number
45 today let me make an offer to you
guys whoever is number 50 on my website
today we're at 45. if you are number 50
at joinpakman.com I'll send you a free
item from my online store t-shirt coffee
mug hat hoodie whatever you want Obama
okay that's that's an offer I'm making
right now
let's see what else we've got here
um
other voicemails
hey David I wanted to give you a
question I think Marco Rubio might be
the most reasonable Republican in the
Republican party what do you think
I don't see so here's the issue
Marco Rubio does not strike me as at all
reasonable
and at the same time I'm struggling to
think of a republican more reasonable
than him
so may I mean it's it's a it's a sort of
a double-edged sword there I'd have to
think about that a little bit more
I have to think about that a little bit
more
see what else we've got here
hi David you said on your stream what is
it about uh Marjorie Taylor Green's
appearance that is so revolting yeah I
think I have the answer to this I I
don't have verification but she owns a
CrossFit gym she's really into is that
true she owns CrossFit Gyms Fitness
um she has been for a long time from
what I understand this because of her
working out and stuff I really think
what we're seeing is steroids I don't
know a thing about that I don't know
anything about Marjorie Taylor green on
steroids I really could not could not
speak to that so I'm going to have to
opt out of commenting
um
let's see what else we've got here
other voicemails that have been coming
in
um
let's see what we got here
hi David uh Colin ginch here uh saw you
peace the other day about solar and heat
pumps and so on which has been my
specialty for the last 30 years or so
nice uh we were installing or
instrumenting
um heat pump installations in Indiana
back in 1985
and uh just an important uh things that
needed to be added to this that are both
Technical and political at the same time
was that heat pumps are expensive but
reducing the heat required or air
conditioning required by the house is
quite inexpensive and it's a well-known
uh procedure there are people that are
trained to do that
um it's come and gone in different forms
over the years but apparently called an
energy audit and uh
we've had bad luck with audits in this
country over the last year and it makes
the solar system work properly along
with the prophesized battery that can be
used to exchange power with the grid
charge your car and so on
so there are obstacles uh we get in the
way of this which is in trans utility
contracts and so on but well listen it's
a very very good commentary and I
appreciate it very much a lot that goes
into that for sure
uh a lot goes into that for sure I want
to say a big thank you to Will Williams
who just signed up on my website
joinpakman.com and his new member number
46 remember number 50 gets a free item
from my online store we are probably one
to three minutes from them returning
let's see what else we got here
what what did he say what was that
could you see any of the European does
he say could we see an image of your
penis is that what that guy said
it was so unintelligible that the voice
to text couldn't even pick it up
let me listen once that's a bizarre
voicemail saving it could you see any of
your penis thank you my God I think
that's what this person is saying
uh
uh can we block a a voicemail number
let's see
uh
oh my God this is a person who's called
50 times
what on Earth
well what a very strange caller yeah
that's
I'm actually seeing I actually think
that that's a caller that may have
already been reported to the FBI
anyway let's um
oh he wanted to see a picture of my
hummus oh that's different that's very
very different
so when I first came out to California
um I'm not like this uh Indian
um he was like
um
HUD come from India
and she was like um like an assassin or
something
um
where he lives
he was fighting like the government okay
well that's uh that's pretty compelling
stuff let's see
um
see what else we've got here
so having watched the uh Junction
election and there was some issue with
his son trying to vote
I theorize that
it was a ploy where he had lost and his
son was able to vote he would have
referenced it saying see even my
underage son was able to vote illegally
I'd love to hear your thoughts on this
yeah we've theorized the same thing that
is that is interesting I am curious
where that caller
was calling from because that was pretty
interesting but that um yeah that that's
certainly something that's been
theorized I want to say thanks to Colors
ATK as well as my bag of mangoes for
signing up numbers 47 and 48 folks we're
getting really close number 50 to sign
up on my website joinpakman.com gets a
free item of your choice from the online
store
and the mango is number 49 folks that
means that the next person to sign up on
my website gets the item or item
depending on your pronunciation
and what part of the United States you
are from that's the that's the next one
in terms of a hummus stream I do have a
pretty solid recipe for for Scratch
hummus it involves really strong
elements of chickpeas I do use tahini
you absolutely want to use tahini
um it includes lemon
parsley is really really strong the the
garbanzos are not homegrown I do admit
that I I do buy the garbanzos I'm not
growing the garbanzos so I guess in that
sense it's not totally scratch made but
um I would consider I've actually been
thinking of getting one of those head
mounted GoPros like Kenji uses and doing
some of my recipes but it's like it's
one of these things where it's a lot of
work and it it's possible nobody's
interested in that but you know I could
do my famous turkey spicy turkey chili
uh I don't know I don't know it's
something something that we could look
at
they shouldn't be denied coverage but
unvaccinated citizens should be charged
a premium like smokers o4 Insurance
that's interesting right if you go and
you say
I'm unvaccinated by choice then you pay
more that's that's interesting that's
definitely interesting that's something
we could we could look at
uh let's see if I've got any other
voicemails here
David what are you doing brisket is pork
no brisket is beef
brisket is beef listen if anybody here
is going to be able to talk to you about
brisket it's it's me and I can assure
you biscuit is brisket is beef it is not
pork it is not pork it's not even close
to Pork I don't even know how to say it
brisket couldn't be further from pork
then
you know peaches
uh let's see
what else I've got here
a lot of voicemails are coming in but
many of them are gutter trash
uh
uh here's one about Marjorie Taylor
green
hey David
um just wanted to make one comment
or maybe two comments uh regarding
Marjorie Taylor Greenpeace and Lauren
Bubba
you know you could take the white trash
out of the trailer but you can't take
the trailer out of the white trash oh oh
my God that is a brutal shot across the
bow I can't approve of that I can't
approve of that because that is
extremely extremely aggressive it's
endlessly it's endlessly prescient but
it is it is a little too too too
aggressive for this program but I do
appreciate that call
um I want to I want to say thank you to
Amy Williams Amy has done something
incredible Amy you are new member number
50 today with the coupon code Obama
Obama and as a result you get a free
item from my store please go to
davidpackman.com gear pick out the item
you want the size and the color email
info davidpackman.com with that
information and your mailing address and
we will get that out to you I also want
to say thank you to Ryan Richardson Ryan
just made a pledge on patreon patreon
pledges count double today which puts us
at 52 and then lastly I want to say
thanks to the mango for both subscribing
via twitch Prime and gifting a twitch
Prime subscription which puts us all the
way up to 54.
N.H Barracks has sent a Tesla related
Super Chat and says I'm a Tesla full
self-driving beta tester oh hold on a
second
exactly I'm a Tesla full self-driving
tester not even close to being a
finished product although marketed as
being very close thoughts on having
people pay 10K to test software for a
company who use subsidies with taxpayer
money seems like fraud fraud exactly so
here's my view
in my vehicle
I did the Tesla uh full self driving
and
um I am now at the point where I am
going to be returning the vehicle and
getting a new one and I am not paying
for FSD
I could I am listen I have been a Tesla
shareholder for seven years
I am a user of the product
I I did it
and I am not going to do it on the next
one because I agree it's just not there
it is just not there we are Live tensed
and Not merged those into the felony
murder counts which were vacated by
operation of law I want to make a
separate argument this is the first time
we heard of this this morning I know of
no law that prohibits the court from
conducting merger before the vacating of
the up by operation of law so in other
words if you were to merge the
underlying felony she's sort of talking
about order of operations remember
please excuse my dear Aunt Sally from
algebra class she's doing it applied
here to charges even need to consider
this but in Noel this Georgia Supreme
Court case this court concluded that the
court the trial court had failed to
sentence on the underlying felonies that
were the predicates for those felony
murder counts that were vacated by
operation of law
but did not automatically say that the
trial court aired in not sentencing on
those in Noel the trial court the
supreme court ordered the trial court to
make a determination and I quote whether
the remaining non-murder felonies merge
as a matter of fact into the felony
murder conviction and that that's why
the case was remanded back and
interestingly in the Noel case the
Hewlett case is cited 296 Georgia 49
that's a 2014 Georgia Supreme Court case
same issue as before about
uh the felony murders
being vacated by operation of Law and
then there but in Hewlett it was a
malice murder case as well
but it gave some instruction
and I suppose that's why the Noel Court
relied on Hewlett gave some instruction
about whether there would in fact be
murder merger and in Hewlett the
important distinction was whether the
felony that then led to felony murder
was followed almost immediately by the
death of another so the question was was
whether there was a quote deliberate
interval between the offense and the
death
for those reasons your honor I asked the
court to find as a matter of fact that
those felonies do merge and that there
is no reason and no statutory obligation
for the court to sentence on the other
remaining felonies that the state wishes
to proceed on
yeah so I understand we're saying what
you're saying is there's no deliberate
interval then because there are other
kids
yes
that's what exactly what I'm saying your
honor that there that all of this took
place in a continuing
manner that there was no stop and start
between the beginning of the chase we'll
call it and the end which led to the
tragic death
so for that reason I think that it can
be distinguished from some of the other
cases that Miss donikovski may be
relying on but it certainly stands for
the proposition that simply because the
felony murders are vacated by operation
of law does not mean that the underlying
felonies have to be
sentenced upon
they don't still exist they don't aren't
still there there still is a question of
merger by operation of fact
this is live folks this is live
tween
the two
story sentencing options
that
are before this court the state is
asking for the sentence of life without
the possibility of of parole
and grab this
they made that position known back in
September of 2020 specifically September
16th of 2020 when they filed a notice of
the state's intention to introduce
evidence in aggravation of punishment
and in that notice your honor under the
final box that's checked
the state indicated that it intended to
seek life without the possibility of
parole
by relying upon three statutory code
sections sixteen five one which is
simply the murder statute
Seventeen ten two which is the statute
of criminal procedure that provides for
what we're doing here today the
presentation of evidence
in support of any sentence that that
each party is seeking
and finally 1710 6.1 is the third code
section on which the state relied in
seeking life without the possibility of
parole and in that code section that is
as the court knows sets forth the
inability for any individual who is
incarcerated for the first time on an
aggravating on a violent felony which
results in a sentence of life with the
possibility of parole to not be
considered for any form of release or
parole until after the service of 30
years in prison
those were the reasons the state said we
seek punishment of the defendant in this
manner and in the at the top of their
notice of seeking aggravation of
punishment the state indicated in
September of 2020 that they intend to
introduce evidence
of any convictions Juvenile
adjudications and other Crimes of the
defendant furnished as part of the
reciprocal discovery
what the court knows
is that there are
no other crimes
and no other pieces of evidence that
support that statutory ground for
seeking aggravation of punishment
so in the absence of that sort of
evidence which is the evidence the state
indicated back in September it would
provide
an absence as the court knows from the
bond hearing and having had those
documents provided to it there is an
absence of any criminal history by Greg
McMichael which is a significant factor
in your consideration of what sentence
to impose
so without any of the aggravating
evidence that was set forth in the
notice the state has told this court now
we wish to Simply rely on the facts of
the case and in particular what Miss
dunikoski argued is number one what she
called a pattern
of vigilantism
but every example she gave your honor
was not in fact vigilantism
using Gathering up folks who have no
authority to do so and taking the Law in
your own hands
her examples were notifications that
Greg McMichael made to law enforcement
about suspicious activity and suspicious
people
in their neighborhood
and in fact that is exactly what a
neighborhood was this seems stronger
than Travis McMichael's lawyer so far
officer rash testified to you we need we
can't survive without
neighbors who will let us know what's
going on and provide us the evidence we
need to investigate crime very different
and not at all related to some sort of
pattern of vigilantism which is a
violent Act
the second fact on which the state said
that they were relying
based on the facts of the case to seek
an aggravation of punishment from a life
with parole meaning no consideration for
anything less than 30 years all the way
up to life with absolutely no window of
opportunity
is that Greg McMichael has shown no
remorse or empathy
the difficulty of our adversarial system
A system that
is the best system we know of
is that it
still leaves no opportunity
for an accused to turn and be the person
you know he's been for 30 years for 66
years and offer condolences
to another person for their sadness and
for their loss
the other problem with the adversarial
system that I know all too well
is that an individual who is committed
to telling the stories
to explaining to a jury how an
individual got where they are right now
often feels
like a defense attack
on the surviving relatives of this loved
one that's true a vigorous defense often
results in the sadness of people who
have lost a loved one
but those are the roles that we
honorably take on
our remaining stoic
in the face of heartbreaking testimony
this morning
from people who have lost a loved one
is because that's our role in this
courtroom this court has very handily
taken care of emotional outbursts to
make sure that we're dealing with law
and facts and not the kind of thing that
can otherwise affect a court or a system
that should remain free of those sorts
of emotions
so your honor
like Mr Rubin said
it really isn't anything that I suspect
the court will be taking into
consideration the fact that Greg
McMichael didn't and couldn't
stand up and offer his genuine sadness
and condolence for the loss of a loved
one
because he's facing other crimes he's
facing charges and trials on other
crimes criminally and civilly
and I hope the court knows that what we
need to do to tell his story
in any case involving
justification of which there was
sufficient evidence to move forward with
a request to charge
is that there has to be a clear
palpable palpable
full-throated
explanation to a jury
about how it is
that an individual put himself
in a place where our clients felt they
had to defend themselves
it must be terribly difficult to hear
when it concerns your loved one who's no
longer here and it probably
feels cold
but the court knows those are our roles
and it's the only way to make sure that
our system operates as it should
so your honor with no statutory
aggravating circumstances like in a
death penalty case how do you decide we
now know there are no
statutory aggravators based on the
notice
we now have told you about how the
factors that the state said arise out of
the trial actually escalate this out of
life with parole to life without parole
I suggest to the court that we rely on a
wonderful system that the federal United
States sentencing guidelines set up and
the United States code and that's you
look at two things you look at the
nature and circumstances of the offense
and you look at the history and the
characteristics of the defendant
let's talk number one about the nature
and Circumstance of the offense
the best indicator of what happened
in order to respect the jury's verdict
is to listen to the jury's verdict
the jury found
that Greg McMichael as a party to the
crime
committed felonies
that unintentionally
led to Ahmad arbory's death
after deliberating for over 10 hours
over two days
they came back with a unanimous verdict
that says in effect Greg McMichael did
not leave his home that day
hoping to kill
he did not view his son firing that
shotgun with anything other
than fear
and sadness
what this jury found is that this was an
unintentional act one that Greg
McMichael did not plan
devise
attempt or seek to have the result that
happen thanks real quick to Molina
Destiny benell II for hosting us welcome
to the 2000 people watching us we're
getting very close to the sentencing
here of the three men convicted of
murdering Ahmad Arbury could be 20 30
minutes never are intended
that tragic result that took place on
February 23rd If you never wanted
another person to die as a result of
activities you took place apart in you
can't be the worst of the worst
secondly your honor under 17 10-2 the
things that this court should consider
you should take it in account
extenuating or mitigating evidence that
you heard in trial
strong sip there
burden trial
based on the presentation of evidence
over several days
that Greg McMichael sought to detain
Ahmad Arbury
for one reason and one reason only it
was not for sport
it was not for evil
it was for the same reason that the
police who repeatedly came to satilla's
Shores came there for it was to get to
the bottom of Ahmad arbory's nighttime
intrusion into Larry english's house
the verdict
spoken by this jury based on their
understanding of the law of citizens
arrest
found that Greg McMichael did not
possess the information he needed to
possess to attempt to execute a
citizen's arrest and that meant that
Travis was not in a position to defend
himself because he was the initial
aggressor if there was no citizen's
arrest that could be supported by the
facts and the law
that is the offense that you heard
a reason
that is not an evil reason not at reason
of hate not a reason of anything other
than trying to help other people
to get to the bottom of this inquiry
further support of extenuating and
mitigating circumstances from The Trial
you saw in the video itself
as painful as it was to watch I'm sure
the court does recall that when you saw
Greg McMichael in the back of the pickup
truck in the bed of the pickup truck
not directing not doing anything that's
going to be the person who's advancing
the progression of this from the chase
the attempt to stop and detain a mod
Aubry into What It ultimately became
you most importantly saw
that Greg McMichael never even sought
to remove his handgun from its holster
until after you heard the first shot
the first shot that took place in front
of that pickup truck
so while he's on the phone
begging for 9-1-1 to come and help
that is the moment he removed his
handgun and never fired a shot
that is the nature and the circumstances
of the offense that this court heard and
upon which the jury reached their
verdict
so now the history and the
characteristics of Greg McMichael yeah I
mean it's it's an impossible task and
she's really going to take every every
opportunity which is her job since
character
Greg McMichael is 66 years old so Ms
done akoski there has not been just 99
Good Deeds
but more like thousands and thousands of
big and little
good acts of kindness
charity
Goodwill throughout this man's life
Greg McMichael is a good man he's not a
perfect person
none of us are
but he's lived a good life
a life dedicated to service and that
does count for something the choices he
made as a Young Man
all the way through the rest of his life
to serve not to acquire wealth not to do
anything that brought extreme attention
to himself
but to quietly go through the business
of choosing career options to help other
people
you heard at the bond hearing and it
during the trial of this case
Greg McMichael chose as a young man to
serve this country by enlisting in the
Navy
and after an honorable discharge
some years later decided to serve his
community
over 30 years in law enforcement
he was not a patrol officer than later A
detective then later a detective excuse
me an investigator with the DA's office
because he sought power there was no
evidence of anything like that
they have were never any complaints
about him being aggressive about him
seeking to take matters in his own hands
without seeking the appropriate backups
he was not a gun-toting aggressive
officer
his wife testified during the bond
hearing one matter of Pride that Greg
McMichael always had is that he never
had to discharge his weapon
during the service of his community
and of course he wasn't a law
enforcement officer or a deta
investigator for the DA's office for
money that's laughable
he did it to help
he did it to Serve and Protect other
people
his post file that the court had into
evidence during the bond hearing
indicated numbers of commendations
and notes from people in the community
indicating how grateful they were for
his willingness to participate in a case
for his willingness to go the extra mile
for his kindness to families of people
who had lost loved ones
things that are above and beyond the
work that he needed to do
those examples of commitment
of empathy and kindness are further
examples of who Greg McMichael is
he is a husband for over 38 years
through thick and thin
to the woman that he met and married
months later
he's a son
a brother
a father
and a devoted grandfather
so yes that's how I stand before you
your honor
representing Greg McMichael who has now
been convicted of murder and I say
without hesitation he remains
a man of goodness wow
for 66 years I thought she was done I
calculated that's 24
105 days of Life on this planet
and we're here
not for a small matter not as if it if
all of the other erases what happened on
that day
but we are here
for a driveway decision to pursue a mod
arbory
and a five-minute chase that ended in
tragedy
he needs to be punished
but how that contrast between a life of
Good Will and service
and the bad decisions that were made
that day that resulted in a tragedy that
the jury said unanimously he never
intended
could
be could end up in the states seeking
the sort of sentence that is devised for
the worst of the worst
is
not consistent
in many courtrooms your honor that I
appear in
right behind the judge and it might be
that way in Chatham County
there is the Seal of the state of
Georgia
and our Georgia state seal
has three words on it
wisdom Justice
but most importantly moderation
life without parole versus life with the
possibility of parole maybe nothing more
than academic
for a 66 year old man with significant
health problems Bob
because it means 30 years at the very
least in prison
but
it is an important
distinction
it will affect all sorts of other things
that could happen to Greg McMichael
while he's in prison
but most significantly
it is the only way your honor to honor
the jury's verdict that Greg McMichael
committed crimes
for which he never intended the result
for that reason
for the lack of evidence of aggravation
for the presence of significant evidence
of extenuation and mitigation we asked
the court to sentence Mr McMichael to
life with the possibility of parole
that's the second of three responses
from defense the third will be Attorney
Kevin Guff for Roddy Brian
he is often the most long-winded
Golf and this this could be five minutes
this could be an hour
it's gonna be so long in fact that he
wants a break it's gonna be so long
let's make it realistic let's take a 10
minute recess and then we'll come back
on the record at quarter two thank you
so uh Kevin Gough known for being
extraordinarily long-winded asking for a
recess and he may be going for a very
very very long time
um
I am not
I I am giving my complete layperson
opinion I am not getting the sense that
the judge is likely to be particularly
moved by the first two statements from
defense counsel
we will ultimately see we will
ultimately see what the deal is with
that thanks to Captain Smiles blueberry
babe Fey deflorite Drake and hash brown
for the twitch Prime subscriptions I
really appreciate that also big thank
you to Jennifer Boyle for signing up on
my website Jonathan Torres as well
putting us at 61. we are in a very brief
10 minute recess I will take it as well
refill my water and then we will be
right back with it
all right welcome back everybody we're
in a very short break here we're sort of
starting to get to the end I think at
least I hope the next thing will be that
Attorney Kevin Guff who's the attorney
for Roddy Brian is going to uh speak he
is going to issue some kind of a defense
uh in mitigation
um and we will see that and then we will
see the final rebuttal from the
prosecution and then presumably
presumably at that point in time we will
get the verdict now I did want to see
here
uh I had one item for you guys this is
just sort of kind of a funny thing of
how how truly ignorant and weaponized
the disinformation from the Fox News
host Maria Bartiromo has become one of
the big pieces of economic news today
was that the unemployment rate is down
to 3.9 percent now you might say David
sir
3.9 it that the unemployment rate is not
the only thing that matters and of
course I would agree with you but this
is just so funny here's Maria Bartiromo
under Trump talking about how fantastic
of an accomplishment it is that we got
the unemployment rate down to 3.9 you
know she's just a hypocrite I think the
rally is really important for the
president you could see that he gets
empowered by all the crowds I mean it
really energizes him but if he does not
communicate his record no one will I
mean we talk about it obviously on Fox
all the time but when you look at some
of the accomplishments wages up 2.8
percent year over year unemployment rate
3.9 percent economic growth 4.1 percent
these are these are pretty basic numbers
which under Joe Biden they don't care
about but under Trump they were just
evidence of you know all these great
things you guys know that these people
are total Hypocrites and you really
can't uh you you just can't listen to
the things that they say
um but uh just just a bit of a note for
you guys
um okay let's get back if we can to a
few more voicemails while we have the
opportunity here although I do expect
them to be back very soon
um let me just pull these up here for
everybody
Okay let's listen
I don't
know and obsessed me so much is that
we're considering the way the right wing
acts and thinks in a political ideology
instead of what it is it's a mental
pathology and I just I read something
that um
Randy Dr Lanny Lee Andy I think it is
Bandy X Lee former guest on the program
indeed on her Twitter and she said once
we allow pathology could be just another
political ideology
um excellent point I see the point
you're making Anna Marie excellent point
let's get back to the case here
all right we're back on defense
president represented by Council uh Mr
Goff Kevin Goff here let me Begin by
making clear that nothing I I say uh
should constitute a withdrawal or
abandonment of any other sentencing or
related or punishment related motions
previously filed
beyond that uh if this were any other
case
when it comes to sentencing I'd be
turning to miss danikovski and saying
judge what she said
um I
uh
I agree in a lot of ways that the the
sentence recommended by the state should
be the Judgment of the Court
but this is not a normal case and
uh we should do over under on how long
this guy talks it could be a very very
long time
and there is one issue that the state
sensory recommendation did not address
I'm pretty sure I know what the answer
would be it won't take them long to give
it but I I would put it on the record
um your honor like Travis and Gregory
McMichael Roddy Brian is a first
offender he has no prior felony
convictions
like Travis and Greg McMichael Roddy
Brian has lived a life
however well lived that warrants an
opportunity and potential for Redemption
and Rehabilitation
I would ask the court to consider the
entirety of the record in the case
including the transcripts of the
pre-trial proceedings including the bond
hearing in this case I'm not going to go
through a whole bunch of rottie's family
history and circumstances I know the
court is familiar with them
the Michael defense teams have argued
elegantly and persuasively for sentences
of life with the possibility of parole
based on the grounds that I've
previously discussed
and like the McMichaels there's no
evidence that Mr Brian is depraved or
among the worst of the worst and
therefore Roddy Brian should likewise be
allowed the possibility of parole
and there is an argument here as to
whether or not the life without parole
option is an option before the court in
this case
um
I didn't think the state had filed a
notice of uh intent to seek life without
parole
and
apparently they did file the notice I'm
not sure
whether they had intended to withdraw
the notice beforehand or what happened
but
in this case the the notice which I
don't recall receiving
was filed in September 2020 it was
emailed to
a Sea Island address not mine which
would be consistent with it not having
been properly surfed and
I would take the position that due to a
technicality beyond the control of the
state in this case and Beyond the
control of the court and the service was
by the previous Chief assistant Jesse
Evans in this case oh boy that
technically not having been served as
provided in the certificate of service
that the notice is defective
there Still Remains an issue as to
whether the court can oppose dissent
could impose sentence anyway without
that notice and that would require the
courts resolving two competing statutes
you have the sentencing statute itself
and then you have 17 16 4 under which
the notice was provided we would suggest
a rule of leanity indicates that where
the notice is not been served or there's
not proof of proper service that the
court doesn't have discretion to impose
a sentence of life for that parole
I'll let the court think about that it
may be an academic question anyway
particularly giving the state's
recommendation which we're certainly not
going to disagree with
um
but beyond putting going beyond that
issue your honor
while Mr Brian is also a first offender
and also worthy of uh Rehabilitation
based on the life that he's lived as the
evidence reflects that's where the
similarity between Roddy Brian and the
McMichael defendants ends and I would
submit to the court that that isn't the
beginning of the sentencing inquiry for
Mr bright the end of the sentencing
inquiry for Mr Brown I would
respectfully submit that it's the
beginning now before getting into that I
do want to address one other
lawyers probably shouldn't use the word
technical arguments uh but oh my God
I would contend that count nine merges
into count eight I don't think alleging
separates streets the that the chase is
occurring on changes it if someone was
chased through the city of Savannah I
don't think that you could argue that
there were 15 different attempts at
false imprisonment or 15 different false
imprisonments if you went down
Montgomery and up MLK and across brought
in up the president and down Julian I
don't think you could multiply counts
that way I think that's a fair argument
nine isn't in KOA defense that obviously
merges into eight and because the motor
vehicle that was used in this case was
used in the context of the chase there's
a factual merger and I think it's more
or less the same argument that Miss Hoge
was making but I could be mistaken
and so I want to adapt her argument as
well to the extent it's expansive Beyond
mine and specifically a recitation of
the Knoll and the Hewlett cases
um
having done that
I want to get into what I think is where
the sentencing inquiry from Mr Brian
really begins because this is a kind of
unusual case he hasn't even started yet
to me there are four additional factors
that the court has to consider in
fashioning a sentence here
and then the question becomes how the
court does that under the the laws of of
our state we've already challenged those
laws the court not surprisingly given
prior decisions of our Supreme Court
whatever standards may be evolving until
the Supreme Court says they have this
court applies the law that we have but
there are four factors here that I think
the court has to
uh the court never has to consider
anything I think the court should
consider
issue number one is the jury verdict
says that Roddy Brian was not a party to
the shooting nor a shooter Roddy did not
kill Mr Arbury
he did not attempt to kill Mr Arbor he
did not intend to kill Mr Arbury he had
no idea that the McMichaels had guns
until moments before the shooting and
that's not just an opinion that's pretty
much the jury verdict when they
acquitted Mr Brian not only account one
but also count two and count six when
they found him not guilty if anything
related to the shooting that's a
reflection of the fact that Mr Brian had
no idea of what was about to happen
that tragedy was certainly not something
that he could have anticipated up until
the moments before and I and by saying
that I'm not trying to get back into the
charge conference issues it's a
different Factor here at sentencing but
Roddy Brian was not a vigilante he was
not a party to any organized effort to
fight crime in Satilla Shores Roddy
Brian really had no idea what was going
on or why until after the tragic death
of Mr Arbury and I think the state
pretty forcefully drove that issue home
during its closing argument in this case
that factor really puts Mr Brian in a
different position
um you know Mr Brian isn't the one uh
who brought a gun he was unarmed
and I think that reflects his intentions
and reflects a significantly lesser
state of culpability
the second issue your honor is the issue
of remorse now like the McMichael
defendants Mr Brian
faces a federal trial and
substantial Federal penalties in the
event of a conviction
uh and I would agree with Mr Rubin that
no competent attorney in the state of
Georgia under these circumstances would
allow a defendant to say anything more
than they already have
but in this case
distinguishing again Mr Brian from the
McMichael defendants
Mr Brown has expressed remorse
whether it's part of the record or not
he expressed remorse about Mr arbory's
death even before he was arrested on
National Television as the Arbury family
of course has not accepted that and they
don't have to your honor and we could
all understand why
but beyond that when you look at his
statements in this case I think it is
readily clear that while Mr Brian has
disputed and continues to dispute
whether things that he did that day
constituted crimes he has never
questioned the tragedy of this death and
has never expressed anything but remorse
over the death of Mr Aubry I'm very
concerned at the number of papers that
are in front of this guy I would submit
in a very different posture from the
other defendants
and I would remind the court and I'm not
going to spend a lot of time on it
because the court heard most of this but
you know during the trial the court
heard the body cam from Mr minchu Mr
Brian admitted from the get-go that he
chased after
Mr Arbury that he was uncertain as to
whether they should have done that
he wasn't running around the scene
trying to influence Witnesses testimony
as the state alleges alleges other
people have done he was very candid and
straightforward and you heard his
demeanor on the video at the crime scene
you heard the uh excerpt from the
interview with Detective Lowry uh and of
course the court has the the entire
statements in the record uh where you
know Mr Brian expressed again regret
that Mr R Berry died he pointed out that
you know
if if his vehicle had collided with Mr
Arbury maybe Mr Aubry would still be
alive
and not in the context of wanting to
hurt Mr Arbury but in the context that
maybe he would still be with us and this
tragedy might have been something less
um it's a little nuts guys beyond that
your honor there were a number of
statements made to investigators secret
special agent Secrets during the
investigation of this case
um which technically I believe these
statements themselves the transcripts
and the videos were admitted in the
evidence that the Jacksonville Hearing
at least that's my practice I don't have
a transcript to look at but that's
normally what I I do and moreover I
think they were tendered in connection
uh with the preparation for the trial
itself and I think technically during
the trial they weren't but it
technically you can consider those
on May 11th Mr Brian I'm referencing
page 69 of that transcript indicated
that he he you know he did not want to
see the video uh in the aftermath of the
shooting he didn't enjoy it he didn't
take any pleasure in that uh on May 13th
at page 75
Roddy Ryan expressed shock to ancient
Secrest uh at the shooting of Ahmad
Aubry referencing page 100 of the
transcript Roddy thought it was
that what Mr assumed thinking might be
putting too much credit to Mr Brian
Ronnie Bryan assumed that Mr Arbury had
done something more serious that was
more to it than going through an open
unsecured construction site
and
that doesn't change the lawfulness or
unlawfulness of his conduct but it does
reflect on his level of remorse at page
101 Mr Brian
says that to agent Secrets it's so weird
because the entire trial this guy just
seems like a terrible lawyer to
non-lawyers like me and there's been no
real good explanation from any lawyer
that I've read about like how this guy
is actually a competent lawyer but I
think he's considered a good lawyer in
Georgia I don't know
he's not going around boasting you
people or bragging about it he's
regretful way back then and that is
before he was arrested
at page 102 he regretted having got
involved in the chase
and your honor I think when you take
those statements in conjunction with the
rest of the evidence in this case
Mr Bryan has done everything he could do
short of confessing to committing
felonies on National Television
that he is remorseful and regretful at
this tragic loss of life
and it's difficult for me to conceive
what more he can do now
is our very family going to be satisfied
with that no they don't have to be
satisfied with that and it you know how
you have to give credit three members of
his family came up here and probably did
uh what were the most difficult things
they've ever had to do is come speak
here and Discord on National Television
effectively about the death of their
child and their brother
and that's difficult
but whether or not they accept Mr
Brian's expression of sorrow and remorse
for the death of Mr Arbury it's for the
court to decide
whether Mr Bryant has expressed remorse
and if he has
what to do about it
and the court May well decide there's
nothing the court can do about it the
felony murder statute prescribes one
punishment a mandatory minimum of life
and I'm not reviewing the legal argument
there but if there's a way the court can
take it into account I'm going to argue
that the court should
the last issue your honor and I think
the court is well familiar with it is Mr
Brian's full cooperation with law
enforcement from day one from moment one
from minutes after the shooting
I'm not going to belabor all the
different things Mr Brian did producing
the cell phone the Night Out video the
numerous statements going through the
area where the shooting took place with
the police to help them understand what
happened that day on a scale of
cooperation
I mean you'd have to put Mr Brian at a
10 out of 10 even a 12 out of 10. I've
never seen a defendant provide that kind
of cooperation most of it no one has
cooperated like Roddy Brian slick
lawyers didn't tell Roddy Ryan to turn
over the cell phone to talk on the scene
on the body cams to go down hours later
to the police department Roddy Brian did
that because he wanted the truth to be
known whatever that was whatever it
meant
so these are all factors above and
beyond anything that apply to the
McMichael defendants as to why Mr Brian
should receive a lesser sentence now
the mandatory minimum in Georgia is life
imprisonment on a felony murder
I'm not going to rehash illegal
arguments what I am going to suggest to
the court though and given the age of
the defendants here
whether Mr Brian is eligible for parole
or not
he's going to be 80 years old under the
current guidelines before he could be
eligible parole
and effectively
even if the court grants life without
parole sentences as the state has
requested to the McMichaels simply
giving Mr Brian a sentence of life with
the possibility of parole still given
the respective ages means that he would
essentially serve the same sentence and
that there would be no options there
so I'm asking this court to consider the
sentencing Mr Brian and Mr Brian only
under ocga
17-10-1 B
which at least in my experience is
relatively rarely employed
but perhaps underused especially given
evolving standards of
uh
with respect to sentencing issues under
1710 1B as I understand it a request for
relief from parole restrictions May
authorize consideration by the parole
board of parole prior to the completion
of any specified time period other
require otherwise required prior to
parole eligibility
uh imposing sentence under this statute
does not Grant Mr Brian parole he still
may never receive parole
he could still die in prison 50 years
from now even if the court grants relief
under 1710-1b all that that does however
is it gives the parole board the freedom
if you call it that the the ability to
parole Mr Brian whenever they see fit
regardless of any statute or rule I
would otherwise prevent it now Mr Brian
still has a long road here
to establish the Redemption and the
rehabilitation that would justify his
ever being released from prison so as
I've explained to Mr Brian this doesn't
guarantee him that he would do one day
Less in prison then he would otherwise
do Under the sentence that the court is
about to impose
but what it does do is provide the
opportunity for the parole board
to exercise this discretion in deciding
whether to release Mr Brian when they
believe it would be appropriate and not
based on some arbitrary
preconceived mandatory minimum time
period before he could be considered and
I believe that this is that rare
exceptional case where relief under 17
10 1 B however fleeting it might be
depending on the circumstances
that this is a case where that would be
appropriate and I would respectfully
submit to the court that is a practical
matter it is the only
it's really the only relief that the
court can give Mr Brian to reflect his
cooperation his expression of remorse
and the other factors that I've reviewed
with the court today and
that doesn't change the sentencing
recommendation I'm concurring with the
state putting aside the legal arguments
about merger and vacating incentives I'm
agreeing with them that the sentence of
Life plus 15 consecutive probation that
that would be the appropriate sentence
in this case I think the only thing that
we really are disagreeing about at this
point is I'm expecting the state is not
going to be excited about 17 10 1B
but I'm asking the court to do that
anyway and in this relatively small
instance and again it may be completely
meaningless depending on how the parole
board views things
10 and 20 years down the line
but it is really the only thing
short of striking down parts of
Georgia's sentencing law on
constitutional grounds it's really the
only thing this Corps can do that would
substantially reflect
if any of us ever are sentenced the fact
that we sat through this guy's speech
should count towards our time served and
it's it's really it's all that this
court really has available to do that
and if for no other reason that's asked
why I would ask the court to do so but I
do think it would be in the best
interest of Justice I mean your honor
Roddy Brian probably
I won't say he's unique but he's pretty
as close to Unique as you can get in in
our Criminal Justice System it's a
felony murder for someone who didn't
kill or attempt to kill or intend to
kill and it's in the context of a
citizen arrest however foolish and badly
guided and misinformed and certainly
however unjustified under the law
there probably isn't another individual
in the entire Georgia prison system
that's in a similar posture and thanks
to the changes legislature has made to
the citizen arrest statute it will
certainly never be an issue again
uh so this is a request that we're
making here on behalf of Mr Brian
that would effectively impact one person
now or in the future in the state of
Georgia and we're not asking that as
special treatment for Mr Brian we're
asking it as treatment that anyone in
his situation
would be asking for given the totality
of circumstances present to the court so
again we're asking the court to impose a
sentence of life imprisonment plus 15
years
but we're also asking the court to Grant
relief under 17 10 1 B
thank you
wow and with that Kevin Goff sits down
thank you
I believe there is now a state from the
state rebuttal
thank you
because there's a number of legal issues
as well as additional argument by the
state is there any particular order
you'd like to hear it in would you like
me to start with Mr Brian first if we're
backward or just go from Travis and why
don't we however the state wishes to
present it I'll be able to follow it I
would imagine wonderful okay so
regarding Mr Brian
um issue
1710 1B actually says
that it will
apply only to first offenders where
technically Mr Bryant is a first
offender he doesn't qualify under the
first offender statute because anyone
convicted a felony murder you're not
allowed to sentence them under the first
offender statute so we have that problem
first but the second problem is is that
it refers back to a and subsection a of
1710 1 actually says except in cases in
which life imprisonment life without
parole the death penalty may be imposed
and then goes through so
B can't even apply to anything that
imposes a life sentence and that's how
the state is reading this because when
you look at
B
the judge in fixing the sentence as
prescribed in subsection a of this code
section
subsection a says except for life
sentences so therefore none of this will
ever apply to a felony murder
conviction
and then
wow
if that's true I don't know I'm merging
into count eight
I understand factually the issue that Mr
Goff has brought up on behalf of Mr
Brian that
two separate instances one an attempt
to confine him taking place on Burford
was just a continuation of something
that was going on and on and on and on
ironically that was not the argument
that Mr Goff made at trial during his
closing argument he actually started to
posit that Mr Brian was actually leaving
and wanting to go home and just happened
to go in the wrong direction back down
homes and that he wasn't actually trying
to commit a false imprisonment on Holmes
he was just trying to go home but
regardless what we have here is an
intervening Factor
um I didn't know Mr Goff was going to
make this argument but I believe there's
a case out there that involves
aggravated assault and aggravated
battery and it involved a man who had
cut the female victim's throat and then
also cut her face the aggravated battery
was on the face the aggravated assault
was on the throat but there was an
intervening time frame
and so on the one hand I do know that
there are numerous cases out there where
if you start shooting at somebody and
then continue to shoot it's all one
aggravated assault
okay there aren't separate aggravated
assaults for each time you fire unless
there is an intervening actual time
frame where you've shot they've run away
you've chased them down and now you're
over on another Street like we have in
this case you've encountered them again
and now you start shooting again because
there's two different locations two
different specific places and times
that allows the state to charge it and
the reason it allows the state to charge
is because what you're really trying to
do is prevent the state from engaging in
double jeopardy you don't want the state
to be able to go on January 3rd on
prefer no on well I'll do our case on
February 23rd 2020 I'm perfect you get
tempted to falsely imprison him oh not
guilty okay well we'll go ahead and move
it over to homes and we'll get a new
indictment and we'll do it over there on
that date so you want to keep the state
from going ahead and doing two different
things in two different bites of the
Apple you want to make sure there's no
Double Jeopardy here well in our case we
don't have double jeopardy here because
we have two different separate instances
and they're both in this indictment
and they're both two separate time
frames yes very close in time between
four minutes I know I'm kind of giving
the court both the defense side and the
state side
but
to be candid with the court there are
cases out there especially the gunshot
cases that say it's all one continuous
action the state's position in this
indictment and one of the reasons we
specifically indicted it this way is
because Mr Brian's attempt at false
imprisonment on Burford was specifically
done with his pickup truck when he tried
to run Mr Arbury off the road and try to
attempt to falsely imprison him right
there with his truck he attempted four
different aggravated assaults on him at
that point in time to get him to stop
there he was unable to do it that's why
it's a criminal attempt
however over on homes
after he went up and chased him up and
then we begin the video and Mr Aubry
turns back Mr Brian does continue to go
a poems he actually goes up homes it's
on video he pulls into a driveway he
says I'm going to go ahead and keep
going he does a three-point turn and
then he comes down homes
he encounters then Mr Aubry coming
around the corner and that is where that
actual false imprisonment absolutely
takes place right there on homes where
Mr arbory's ultimately falsely
imprisoned
and killed so these are two separate
distinct incidences and there is no
chance of double jeopardy
because
both of these things are distinct they
took place at separate places and
separate time frames within the incident
so we asked the count nine it's crazy
how much better she is than these other
lawyers obviously affected by the fact
that she has the facts on her side the
way we're doing this I did want to point
uh to the court to another case
with respect to this issue that's been
drawn back to the merger issue that I
raised and that is the point is whether
or not it's a continuing offense
what is this person holding right here
is what is she on oxygen what is that do
you guys see that what is that moved an
exportation occurs
all the places during that movement are
one crime and I'll cite to the court
Hill versus the state 279 Georgia app
666 a 2006 case that's cited in browse
it's a dictation device of some kind
699 a 2009 okay it says that the offense
of kidnapping is complete when in this
instance Brower sees the victims oh is
it because this lawyer is off mic so
there it's being repeated
and when he taped up and moved the
attorney from place to place in the
office so the movement is the question
is if kidnapping is not a continuing
offense then he is not going for this
argument is she I've done search and I
just don't have the answer to that and I
yeah let's we'll keep the state to its
argument I
understanding that with with the
kidnapping the issue here I think is
slightly different
uh as I understand what the state's
arguing is the way that false
imprisonment and the attempt was alleged
in the indictment was that the attempt
occurred on Burford there was an
intervening interval and then later
short period later but later
there was a completed act on hold that's
the argument that's the argument that I
understand is being presented and that's
why I'm going to look at the merger part
of it now how that fits and whether or
not it merges I'm probably going to take
a few more moments to think that through
and how that works
but that's what I understand we're
looking at as far as the legal issues
and understand the kidnapping part of it
you have a kidnapping just because you
move them within the office we're not
going to allege it flip side of that is
I mean you look at some other statutes
like the I won't tip it windmills but
when you look at police chases I mean
you can be charged with obstruction
five times in the same Chase so I mean
they're the issue
may seem simple but it's not but this is
the way I'm going to approach it
thank you judge and I believe the reason
for the merger
um really comes down to the issue of
Double Jeopardy because you have to put
the defendant on notice because you do
not want there to be an opportunity for
the state to come back with double
jeopardy which is why you want to get as
specific as possible and which is what
we did in order to designate these two
separate instances in time and in place
so that is the state's argument as far
as count nine merging into count eight
and that is what I have for Mr
goth
now
your honor with regard to the legal
argument that Miss Hogue made on behalf
of Greg McMichael
um
Noel was then cited in the case of
Jeremy Scott who killed Dexter holiday
it was a Fulton County case
embarrassed to say it was my own and in
that case we had to resentence Mr Scott
because what the court did was sentenced
him
on a felony murder conviction but then
actually when he was found guilty of
possession of firearmed by a convicted
felon
the court went took the possession of
firearm by a convicted felon merged into
the felony murder then merged the felony
murder into the felony murder for the
armed robbery
and the court went and cited to Noel and
this is Scott versus the state 302
Georgia 29. it's a 2017 case the state
notes that based on Noel versus the
state the trial court aired in merging
the felony murder convictions and then
merging the predicate felonies into the
remaining murder conviction
when the trial court sentenced Scott on
Count 2 the felony murder based on
aggravated assault count three felony
murder based on possession of farm by
convicted felon was vacated by operation
of law therefore count six possession of
a firearmed by convicted felon then
cannot merge into count three which
stands vacated
we therefore vacate the merger of count
six into account three meaning the
possession of Fire by convicted felon
into the felony murder that it's based
on and remand for resentencing on count
six now if actually
you are a convicted felon at the moment
you're shooting that person it happens
at the exact same time so I think that
kind of goes towards that well if it's
all happening at the same time it needs
to uh merge together and
I will also direct the court to a case I
affectionately call the El Camino case
once again unfortunately mine uh this is
Demarcus Graves it is Graves versus the
state 298 Georgia 551 once again a 2016
case
at that point in time basically it said
while the evidence was sufficient to
sustain Springs graves's conviction
we find an error in sentencing the trial
court purported to merge two felony
murder counts with the malice murder
count
the trial court then purported to merge
two independent felonies criminal
attempt to commit armed robbery and
possession of firearm by a convicted
felon with the two murder counts
and basically what they said in Graves
was no you can't merge the felony
murders into murder you have to vacate
them by operational law and once they're
vacated by operation of law that's going
to leave you with the possession of
firearm by a convicted felon in the
criminal attempt to commit armed robbery
therefore the trial court is required to
vacate that portion of its sentencing
order purporting to merge the two
independent felonies
and impose proper sentences on those
counts which I then had to go ahead and
do and resentenced Mr Graves to the
murder car charge with those two
particular felonies so there are two
cases right there that show that that is
not the case because they murdered Mr
Graves while attempting to Rob him of
his drugs while he was sitting in his El
Camino in the parking lot of an
apartment complex while being convicted
felons all of that took place at the
exact same time so therefore Noel does
not stand and has been overruled
basically by Scott and Graves
so with regard specifically now two
Greg McMichael
the idea that there was no vigilantism
here because after they confronted
people after they took their guns to
confront people after they confronted
those people with those guns then they
would call the police is somehow a
neighborhood watch situation as officer
rash testified
they're supposed to be Witnesses that's
what neighborhood watch is there for
they're supposed to be great Witnesses
officer rash said he thought Greg
mcbeiko be the best witness being a
prior law enforcement officer that he'd
be able to come in and take the stand
and say what he saw that's what
neighborhood watch is supposed to be not
somebody running after people in a
residential neighborhood where there are
women and children and people out
walking on a regular basis this was a
Sunday afternoon it's a miracle they
didn't run into families taking a walk
that day and on a random day when the
gbi went out with the Drone videos and
were just going through the neighborhood
they captured numerous people out taking
a walk a family with children were there
so the next point
that Greg McMichael has shown no remorse
or empathy because he's unable to
well Gregory Michael
was a law enforcement officer
but what he did
on May 5th of 2020
was release evidence in an ongoing
investigation into himself into his son
Craig McMichaels the one who released
the video to the media he went to Mr
Brian and said hey give me your phone
I'm going to take it to my lawyer took
it to his lawyer and had his lawyer
release it publicly because he believed
it was going to exonerate him oh my God
that's interference with administration
of justice yes we did not charge him
with obstruction or anything like that
but the fact of the matter is is this is
someone who is in law enforcement for
years
and actually actively pursued evidence
in a case against him to be released to
the media because he believed that that
video showed he and his son
were not guilty of anything that's two
months afterwards
the state's position is he hasn't
changed his mind
State's position is he and his son still
believe they didn't do anything wrong
and that is a lack of remorse or empathy
the idea that he did not intend the
death of Ahmad Arbury once again as a
law enforcement officer got a gun went
running after somebody
the jury did find that he intended to
commit false imprisonment criminal
attempt at false imprisonment aggravated
assault with that pickup truck and
aggravated assault with that shotgun
and we all know that felony murder
has a foreseeability component to it
Ahmad arbory's death was foreseeable and
especially foreseeable
to someone in law enforcement
the idea that they wanted to get to the
bottom of what
an unknown person was doing in some
neighbor's house a neighbor they didn't
even know goes back to our vigilantism
this whole idea that they were trying to
help the neighborhood out has been an
excuse from both Travis and Greg
McMichael
Miss ho got up here and said this wasn't
advancing the progression of the crime
and I apologize for this once again your
honor but stop or I'll blow your [ __ ]
head off uh-oh I think that really
advances the progression of the crime
you're threatening to murder somebody
you're threatening to kill him if he
does not stop
and referring back to the Post
records produced in the bond hearing
Greg Greg McMichael was so not paying
attention to his job as a law
enforcement officer that he was not post
certified from January of 20 2006
through 2014.
he was an investigator in the district
attorney's office and he led his
post-certification lapse from 2006 to
2014 eight years
I won't even go into what that could
have meant to those cases that were
prosecuted by the District Attorney's
office he then lost the post
certification again in 2018 and Jackie
Johnson had to make an accommodation and
change his designation at his job just
so he could keep his job through
retirement
this attitude of I'm special and I'm
above the law and the law doesn't apply
to me and I can take my gun and I can
run after people and confront the
homeless guy under the bridge and then
call the police later about it that's
vigilantism and that is the main reason
the thoughtlessness the remorselessness
the desire so to be special and protect
himself and his family by taking
evidence and releasing it publicly when
he knows there's an ongoing
investigation is the reason we are
asking for life without the possibility
of parole
and with regard
then to Travis McMichael
[Applause]
there's a reason your honor you did not
Grant bond to Travis and Greg McMichael
right Mr Rubin went back to all of those
things listed in the volunteering the
state will also direct the court to
things the state presented in the
volunteering including his text messages
with all of his offensive racial animus
and language
the jury did find that he had an
abandoned and malignant heart that's
exactly what the jury found
they were given that he intentionally
went ahead and did this or the other
level abandoned a malignant heart
in addition I will remind the court that
there's an old saying the road to hell
is paved with good intentions and it's
great that they had such good intentions
to protect the neighborhood
but the thoughtlessness the lack of
vision to know how this could go
terribly terribly wrong
and the fact the matter is genre it was
a year and a half February 23 2020.
November
2021 Travis came in here and testified
the state asks that you take into
consideration his demeanor his attitude
he said this was the worst day of my
life well how'd that work out for a mod
Aubry
not once not once did he show any
empathy or ability to place himself in
the position of Mr Aubry on the stand
and yes
four minutes of conduct
well
four minutes of conduct
Usain Bolt
won eight gold medals
when he runs those races they're less
than two minutes long
but the reason he's able to do that the
reason he is able to win is because of
20 years of training that leads him to
those two minutes
those four minutes are a reflection and
a result of an entire lifetime of Travis
McMichael and his attitude
his demeanor
what he believes he's entitled to go
ahead and go do
the same applies to Greg McMichael well
that four minutes of conduct wasn't just
four minutes of conduct
it was a culmination
of visual anti-ism
a week ago ahead and
play law enforcement even though we're
not
and that we're going to go out and
confront people and we're going to take
our guns to go do it called LARPing
without any real understanding or
consideration of the consequences
at this time for Travis McMichael these
are the reasons that we are asking for
life without the possibility of parole
thank your honor there it is ladies and
gentlemen so tell me in chat is anybody
getting parole argument and evidence
presented and I say that just to be
clear on the record uh there had been
some discussion with Council about
evidence and the record
um the court is going to leave the
record open as I understand it for
what's going to amount to a notice of
filing and two affidavits just in order
to preserve arguments made during the
trial on appeal I'm going to take about
10 minutes maybe 15 minutes and go
through my notes and then the court will
pronounce sentence we are in recess for
Wow 15 minutes here we go folks this is
going to be it
um let's update
stream titles
uh sentencing
[Applause]
let's call it I guess it's live now in
some sense
um
I mean I guess it already is the right
title I don't know
um
wow this is uh
this is gonna end in 15 minutes and then
we will all be able to say with
certitude what it is that is taking
place here uh thanks to people who have
been with us all day we are now into
hour five is almost complete this may go
into hour six or not I think at the uh
within I think he's going to be very
quick in getting back here
um I want to say thanks to Captain
smiles and blueberry babe for the twitch
Prime subscriptions number 62 and 63. I
really appreciate everybody's support
um let me see if I have any Isaac says
David were any of the defendants antifa
yeah I mean it's like it's it's all it's
almost the only thing that Kevin Guff
didn't try which was
um somehow invoking antifa
um let's see if we have
any voicemails related to the sentence
it doesn't look like it
Dan Kraut sends a five dollar Super Chat
let's listen hi David this is Michael
from Oregon I'm calling just to point
out the hypocrisy of people leaning into
monoclonal antibody treatment when that
was treatment developed by stem cell
research fetal stem cell research and uh
the people taking it are the same people
who claim to be Christians and against
things like yeah that's only one of
about four different layers of hypocrisy
when it comes to the monoclonal antibody
stands
um
here's another voicemail
um I'm calling in reference to your
interview with pillow
um and I'm going to talk about his wall
art it pictures a silhouette of uh Jesus
with the the
Crown of Thorns uh and a lion right so
there
I want to point to the Republican uh the
marriage with uh that kind of religion
how it's been cultivated for for decades
and how it has metastasized and nobody's
nobody's called it out and the the
imagery used there you know these these
these Republicans have never read the
news okay I think I get the point yeah
pillow is very much another one of these
uh so-called Christians who seems to not
not actually be that Christian when you
get down to it I want to say thank you
to sapican gel and tylus for the twitch
Prime subscriptions let's see uh some
messages are coming in Via Super Chat
Kevin says can we get an amen for all
the black pastors yeah let's see let's
actually find that moment
um Kevin Guff black pastors this was a
surreal moment only moved from his trial
into the fifth sixth and 14th amendments
of the U.S Constitution parallel
provisions of the Constitution oh wait a
second no that wasn't it
um here it is idea that we're going to
be
seriously bringing these people in to
sit with the victim's family one after
another
obviously there's only so many pastors
they can have and if that their pastor's
Al Sharpton right now that's fine but
then that's it we don't want any more
black pastors
it's even more insane now going back to
uh what it was well listen it's it's all
coming to a close in mere moments the if
you're just joining us we are at a
critical moment
we have had a full day of hearings and
aggravating circumstances and mitigating
circumstances and rebuttals and and
legal motions
um the judge has asked for 10 to 15
minutes of which five to ten remain and
then he is going to render sentence on
the three individuals so if you just see
the next 20 minutes these are the 20
minutes of the day to see
uh whoa
Jason says the FBI was behind this not
antifa get it right agents were
everywhere yeah or even the Deep State
we could say
um
okay here's I'm sometimes I'm told PBS
stays live in the room let's see if we
can go over there if we go to PBS
um
our berry
see what we can find here
they're not live in the room either it
seems that everybody has sort of gone to
this
but we are just moments moments moments
from this
maybe we'll stick here
um
okay
other super chats
in these cases has the judge made up his
mind already or could the judge be
swayed at this point in the proceedings
that's a great question for the lawyers
in the audience at this stage of the
game
is there really something if the judge
was already thinking no parole that
could get him to do possibility of
parole
I would love to hear from from lawyers
uh about that
Belinda sends a five dollar Super Chat
Avi says he wants a shout out for his
friend Michael that it's Michael's
birthday happy birthday Michael you
didn't get me with that you didn't get
me with that but very nice attempt Avi
you did you shot your shot and
unfortunately sometimes it's an air ball
it does happen to all of us
um
okay we are continuing at any moment we
are getting these verdicts it is just a
matter of minutes at this point I want
to say a monster thank you to tylus 93
for gifting 20 subscriptions over on
Twitch I really appreciate that tylus
um as we as we get close to the end of
today's streaming day I do want to
remind everybody that we are doing a
David Pacman show chess tournament
Tuesday at 6 PM Eastern you can join the
chess club at davidpackman.com chess
this is free I'm not selling anything
it's just a community event to build
Goodwill and all of these different
things so that is Tuesday January 11th
at 6 PM I hope that you will play also
next Saturday meaning eight days from
today we will be live with what is
believed expected to be some major
announcement from the former president
Donald Trump during a live rally in
Arizona
um davidpackman.com chess is the URL
well davidpackman.com chess
is the URL quite straightforward
if you're just joining us you haven't
missed you've missed hours of testimony
and arguments not testimony arguments
but we are now within five or ten
minutes of the sentences the judge is
just looking over the arguments made
today and is making a final decision
about sentencing it is within the next
five to ten minutes so don't don't tune
away now because this is really the
critical moment we would love to have
your support on our website
joinpakman.com you can sign up we have a
coupon code Obama oh the origins of that
coupon code are here
uh wait here it is
whoa hold on here's the origin big
trouble remember that
Rock voted against the border wall oh
that's a good thing to him he voted
against Kate's law and he voted for
Obama amnesty
so there it is those are the oranges of
that quote
and uh you can it's it's it is it's
Timeless in a way it really is and you
can take advantage of the fact that
that's funny by signing up at
joinpakman.com Graham who's a defense
attorney
answering the question about could a
judge really be swayed at this point or
has the judge decided
Graham says it depends on the judge this
judge seems reflective and thoughtful
and has probably given this case due
consideration I would assume he had a
good idea what he was going to do
beforehand yeah that's certainly
sensible Sensible in every sense
hi Will
has subscribed via twitch and I really
appreciate that you're number 86 today
very very much a pleasure having you
here
um
yeah a lot of people are confused
we're about to get the verdicts we're
about to get the verdicts Isaac says
Pacman sir hold on
sir sir
I'm an MBA grad student but I want to do
what you do what are your thoughts well
I got an MBA as well so you're on the
same path as me
uh
uh beyond that I don't really know what
what else I can say but I also was once
an MBA student
uh let's see we got a couple voicemails
maybe about the case
a service department
um I thank you see if you might
interview represented
Ayanna Presley she's welcome anytime
Ayanna Presley is at welcome absolutely
anytime she would like on the program
uh without a doubt without a doubt
um
okay some people are getting very very
angry in the chat we did unfortunately
have to ban what what are probably
dozens of people today let me see if
anybody disagreed with the ban and has
filed an appeal no doesn't look like it
seems like they were all good bands as
we might call them
um
inbred is a term that we have allowed
now that the term inbred was used a lot
today we've allowed the term inbred
um
who else was banned
yeah so here here's like an example of
where like you're just gonna get banned
and one of our moderators handled this
one within wow two minutes and this
person was banned David pakman you
absolute ape David packman you're a damn
joke you and your followers are all
inbred y'all ain't nothing but a bunch
of femboy cry babies y'all ain't nothing
but Almond Breeze drinking Apes I bet
y'all wear your mask while in the car
alone they were banned and that was a
really really good band so they're
staying banned inbred is allowed but in
that context it's not a lot of spammers
too today just kind of sad
said that this is what people are
wasting their time on
Isaac says thanks helps a ton elements
of bathrooms elements of bathrooms yes
thank you Isaac very very much
um
nobody's missed anything nobody's missed
anything the judge asked for 15 minutes
to go over his notes that was
11 minutes ago so we are very close if
you tune away now you very much may miss
the verdict Lucian says David sir hold
on I've got a different sir
David sir do you think Novak Djokovic
should be able to play in the Australian
Open although not vaccinated love your
content listen at this point
it's not clear that vaccination slows
the spread of Omicron greater than a
little bit it prevents serious illness
and for that everybody should get
vaccinated
it is not for me to say what Australia's
rules should be it is known that these
are Australia's rules so the idea now oh
oh my goodness they're not letting me in
these have been Australia's rules for a
long time
not a surprise
um just dinny says hang them high mecca
says I enjoy a good selection of meats
and cheeses in bread and toasted
Swami live says David sir can you please
play elements of water do I have that
one hold on let me see
is it this one surrounded by water big
water oh no that's not it
uh
uh was it this one of the wettest we've
ever seen from the standpoint of water I
don't know that I have elements of water
that's the closest I've got
uh thanks to P Ford P Ford has grabbed a
twitch Prime subscription which is
extremely exciting
Logan
okay we're gonna get away from that you
almost got me there Logan but we're not
we're not going for it oh man that is
we're just we're just not gonna do it
yeah sir your wife is up in the air is
one of the best Clips sir your wife is
up in the air yep without a doubt
okay
um let's see what else we've got here
voicemail
hi David this is Ryan from Baltimore a
long time this uh listener
um I'm just want to hear your opinions
on kind of the decline of uh Joe Rogan
um especially his anti-vac stances and
kind of the attack on
um media Outlets like CNN who
um you know covered it well that he was
promoting kind of a drug that wasn't
effective in treating covid even though
it improved it isn't condition improved
but you know not related to that drug um
just wanted to hear your thoughts about
it yeah I mean listen when you take six
different treatments for something that
most people recover from in a week
anyway it's impossible to point to any
one aspect of that and say this is why I
recovered I mean in terms of the
audience thing Rogan's audience has
dramatically declined since the move to
Spotify but he went to Spotify I would
imagine for the money not for the
audience it was clear that taking away
the full episodes from the YouTubes was
going to was going to have that effect
um so I don't know uh yeah I mean that's
sort of that's sort of what it is
um
I don't know that I have too many other
thoughts on it other than you know I've
issued individual critiques of things
Joe Rogan has said
on a one on a case-by-case basis and
that's basically it all right we are now
I think 15 minutes from when the judge
asked for 15 minutes yes we are so any
second any second we should be back in
and on the record
Cyrus Palmer said sir David I don't know
what I'm doing
Kendall says I had that conversation
with my sister I talked to you about
Wednesday it went well she says she'll
be respectful with her whenever they
meet oh yeah Kendall called into the
show the other day and said I have a
sister
and I have a friend the friends
conservative my sister's liberal my
sister said don't hang around with a
friend and I said listen I would just go
to your sister and say
you know please be respectful this is a
friend of mine you know we just have
some political disagreements let's let's
be reasonable thanks to Stanley minarik
for the patreon pledge patreon counts
double today which puts us at 89. the
Dustin Briggs says David sir what about
making your soundboard available for
purchase and download could succeed Big
League massive dumps of downloads
yeah I don't know how I would make my
soundboard available for download
if somebody wants to email info at
davidpackman.com with some ideas
I'm open to sharing the soundboard I
just don't know exactly what that would
mean necessarily
um
let's see here other voicemails that
have come in
hello from Alaska this socialist
Democrat veteran salutes you beautiful
see what else we've got here
hey uh it's me Joshua Breeze love
um I'm just I've been a long time
follower I wanted to know what you
personally David Pacman has thought
about the Trevor Noah
um statues that they have put up for the
Donald Trump Insurrection I don't know a
thing about it unfortunately I wouldn't
I wouldn't be able to uh
I wouldn't be able to comment
unfortunately haven't heard of it
just Denny says person woman man camera
TV very well said
hi there David
um sorry to bother you again um this is
Dustin brush I was the one who chimed in
at the end of your uh segment today
um
I just wanted everyone to just step back
for a moment just just watch your your
just sit back and observe your own
videos
oh okay it's very very hard to
understand Dion says David let you know
why you didn't post my last Super chats
thanks keep up the good work I I'm
trying to keep up with everything you
know when when when we are in session
with the trial
um you know typically I'm not going
through super chats at that point in
time
let's see what else we've got here
according to fair and cousins bring the
fire the mega hat burning started in
2017.
okay very very important statement from
Farren I would never doubt faren
hello David
real quick
Taylor green is bragging about you know
her finds building up for not wearing a
mask in the capitals and um you know
that's supposed to be some sort of
punishment but really the message I feel
like that's pending is that he gets to
pay to do whatever he wants does she
pays the fine she doesn't have to ignore
any laws or rules and what a horrible
example this set if that's the rule why
do they even let her in the building
right
I mean I think there are bigger issues
with Marjorie Taylor shockingly her not
wearing a mask isn't even the biggest
issue
um
see what else we've got here
we do have a new new voicemail from
Whitney
December instead and I I sent this to
you in an email
um and it's like that movie Limitless
where it's like little calculations that
like add up
um and to like a general feeling of
um
uh that adds up to like some feeling of
value
um
man I don't know what Whitney's talking
about
David sir you're sending out like
strong Boomer energy on those kids menu
stuff man
and we are back it is time for
sentencing in this trial it is time for
sentencing in the trial the judges back
and will render sentences
standby all right the uh the way the
Court's going to address this I'm going
to make a few remarks
and then address each one of the
defendants with regard to sentencing and
the remarks are intended to be General
but also taken into consideration in the
individual sentencing portion of the
Court's statement
so that's how we intend to proceed
so the court has heard the evidence
in the case
as
accepted the jury's verdict
listened to the presentations here today
in aggravation and mitigation
and candidly have spent a lot of time
thinking about this
this is a case that has
taken a lot of time and energy on a lot
of people's parts
and has been a case of note not just in
this community but really in a lot of
communities
but we're here today to determine is
what an appropriate sentence is quite
separate from the notoriety of the case
and any other outside influence that may
exist
and so the court is going to be very
careful in explaining that the court has
considered just the evidence and what is
appropriate under the circumstances this
case to consider in the superior court
so that all being said
let me start with this statement
as we all now know based upon the
verdict that was rendered in this court
in November
Ahmad Aubry was murdered
the tragedy
it's tragedy on many many levels
almost 20 I'm sorry on February 23rd of
2020 almost two years ago
a resident of Glenn County
a graduate of Brunswick High a son a
brother a young man with dreams was
gunned down in this community
as we understand it he left us home
apparently to go for a run
and he ended up running for his life
he entered the English home at
approximately 104 pm and left that home
at about 108 on that day
at 1 14
Greg McMichael calls 9-1-1 to let them
know that there's a black male running
down the street
and within moments Ahmad Aubry is shot
and killed
the three men that are now before this
court chased him in a residential
neighborhood
for at least five minutes
in pickup trucks
armed with a shotgun and a 357 revolver
State mentioned this today about the
time period but I do want to put that
time period in context and the only way
I could think to do so maybe a little
theatrical but I think it's appropriate
I want to solve it a concept of time so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to sit
silently for one minute
foreign
represents
a fraction of the time
that a mod Armory was running in Satilla
Shores
this is the sentencing guys the judges
in the middle of a statement this all
day has been building to this so this is
you just want to see the sentence it's
about to be read very very soon
continued confusion in the chat we're in
sentencing
it's going to be about
you know five or ten minutes would be my
guess
that's approximately a minute
again
the chase that occurred in Satilla
Shores occurred over about a five minute
period
and when I thought about this I
thought from a lot of different angles
and I kept coming back to the terror
that must have been in the mind of the
young man running through Satilla Shores
the jury heard the evidence and returned
a verdict and what a difficult job they
had under the circumstances without any
comment on the verdict itself
I think all Council will agree and
accept that this was a very difficult
case to even get a jury impounded on and
there are issues out there with regard
to the jury that were brought up in the
press and elsewhere but I I want to give
credit to those members of the panel not
because of their verdict just because of
the fact that they were willing to go
through the process that they went
through with the state with the defense
and with this court
we're here today to sentence the
defendants
and discharging the duty this court is
required to consider all mitigating and
aggravating circumstances
the court has considered those
circumstances
including but not limited to all aspects
of the crimes charged the past criminal
record or lack thereof of the defendants
I've also considered any lawful evidence
which tends to show the motive of the
defendants
their lack of remorse their General
moral character and any predisposition
to commit other crimes
now I think in this case the record
speaks for itself
and the defendant's own words I think
guide this court with regard to
sentencing
went back through the my notes and other
resources to pull some of the quotes
that we have in this case
I'll start with Greg McMichael
in my opinion Greg McMichael very early
on in this tried to establish a
narrative
he made comments like Ahmad Arbor is
trapped like a rat
stop or I'll blow your and I won't
repeat it again head off
he effectively admitted that he wasn't
sure what Ahmad Aubry had done wrong
quote I don't think the guy has actually
stolen anything out there or if he did
it was early in the process
but he keeps going back over and over
again into this damn house
getting back to the narrative told
Travis you have no choice
told another individual at the side or
the scene this guy ain't no shuffler
this guy is an [ __ ]
this is not looking good though comment
that he wanted him a mod arbory to know
that we weren't playing
if I could have gotten a shot at the guy
I would have shot him
Travis McMichael
claims he was in shock
but it's interesting because he talks
about his concern for his child and his
own well-being
part of this was while the victim was
actually laying there in the street
commented this is the worst day of my
life well I think it's been touched on
here today there were other individuals
that were impacted
I look at the video of this incident
when I say the video I think everybody
knows we're talking about but there was
one part of it that struck me as
absolutely chilling and that is I
believe it's in the enhanced video
provided by the gbi
there's a frame where I believe in mod
Aubry it looks to be iffy's 20 yards out
that may be close 30 yards out it's the
frame of Travis McMichael lifting the
shotgun
to fire the mod Aubry
and you watch that
with context I want to say context after
hearing the evidence in this case again
thinking about a young man
that have been running at that point for
almost five minutes and it is it is a
chilling
truly disturbing
scene
and we got there because
Travis McMichael's father saw Ahmad
Arbury hauling down the street
and calls out let's go
at that point Travis McMichael despite
whatever may have been going on in his
life at that time
regard to family or otherwise
just goes grabs a shotgun and goes
because he assumes that it is the right
thing to do
Montgomery Aubry was then hunted down
and shot
and he was killed
because individuals here in this
courtroom
took the law into their own hands
Mr Brian
he joined in after calling out to the
McMichaels you all got him
claimed he didn't know what was going on
but obviously wanted to know if this
individual who was running through the
neighborhood who he didn't know
had been caught in some way
said quote I figured he'd done something
wrong but I didn't know for sure all
right that wasn't actually the quote
those quotes are two separate quotes
didn't know for sure
I thought he would get away
and this is the part that is disturbing
to me with Roddy Brian if the guy would
have stopped this would have never
happened
all of these quotes give context I think
to the video that we saw during the case
and Miss Wanda Cooper Jones this morning
made a statement that I think when you
look at these statements and you see the
videos is very true and that is she said
when they could not scare or intimidate
him they killed him
there's been discussion about remorse
and I agree with Council that it is it
is dangerous for defendants who have
multiple prosecutions against them to
make statements of remorse but remorse
isn't something that is simply a
statement of regret remorse I think
can be determined by looking at
somebody's reaction to difficult
circumstances than the reality of the
situation that they're in again it
doesn't require an apology and quite
honestly sometimes apologies are made
simply to get past
problems remorse is something that's
felt and demonstrated
in this case
getting back to the video
again after a Marta Aubry fell
the McMichaels turned their backs
it's a again a disturbing image and they
walked away
this was a killing
it was callous
and it occurred
as far as the court is concerned based
upon the evidence
because confrontation was being solved
I think the statement was made during
closing arguments it's interesting to
note that the most violent crime in
Satilla Shores
was the murder of Ahmad Arbury
so sentencing does not generally provide
closure I think Miss Wanda Cooper Jones
also talked about closure but I don't I
don't find that it really does and I
think that's an unfortunate thing
because in this case I think many people
are seeking closure
the mother the father
the community
and maybe even parts of the nation but
closure is hard to Define and is a
granular concept
it seemed differently by all depending
on their perspective and the prism of
your lives
instead of closure maybe be best to see
today's proceeding as an exercise in
accountability
we are all accountable for our own
actions sometimes in today's day and age
that statement is lost upon many
and today the defendants are being held
accountable for their actions here in
Superior Court
today demonstrates that everybody is
accountable to the rule of law
taking the Law into your own hands is a
dangerous endeavor
I'm not sure how this comes across
let's stay in any way
I think ultimately
with regard to the murder of mod Aubry
it all it holds us all accountable
I've read somewhere and I don't remember
where it was
that at a minimum Ahmad aubry's death
should force up his death should force
us to consider expanding our definition
of what a neighbor may be and how we
treat them
I argue that maybe a neighbor is more
than the people who just own property
around your house
I believe that is I also believe that in
assuming the worst in others
we show our worst character
assuming the best in others is always
the best course of action
and maybe those are the grand lessons
from this case I will let others spend
as much time as they want writing about
it and talking about it but those are my
general Thoughts with regards to this
case and sentencing
[Applause]
that said with regard to the sentence in
this case as to Travis McMichael
Mr McMichael the court sentences you as
follows count one
malice murder life without the
possibility of parole there it is Count
two felony murder was vacated by
operation of law count three felony
murder vacated by operation of law count
four felony murder vacated by operation
of law count five felony murder vacated
by operation of law
count six aggravated assault merges into
count one
count seven aggravated assault the court
sentences the defendant to 20 years
consecutive to count one wow count eight
false imprisonment merges into count one
count nine attempted false imprisonment
five years concurrent to count seven
okay that is life Plus 20.
Greg McMichael the court sentences you
as follows
count one malice murder defendant was
found not guilty count two felony murder
life without the possibility of wow
count three felony murder vacated I want
to say vacated it's vacated by
operational law in all cases I'm just
I'm not going to repeat it
count four vacated count five vacated
count six merges into count two
count seven aggravated assault 20 years
consecutive to count two
count eight ten years concurrent to
count seven
count nine five years concurrent to
count seven that is life plus twenty
years wow Rowdy Brian I do want to
separate
[Applause]
a little bit because the state is making
a different recommendation
and despite the back and forth that Mr
Goff and I had during this case I do
want to point out a couple things that
he raised that I think are appropriate
to raise with regard to the sentence
um
as far as the remorse I think Roddy
Brian stands in very different shoes
it is obvious from the beginning
uh that he questioned the tragedy that
had occurred at the scene and was on uh
I believe I can't remember whose body
cam but the body cam in fact questioning
whether or not what had occurred had
occurred and then took Steps early on in
this process I think that demonstrated
that he
had grave concerns that what had
occurred should not have occurred and I
think
that does make Mr Brian's situation a
little bit different
however Mr Prime has been convicted of
felony murder
and I do not believe it can be disputed
based on the facts of this case that the
verdict was an appropriate verdict based
upon the evidence presented at least and
when I say appropriate what I mean is
legal
um
because I believe there's some been some
discussion about some differences
between Mr Brian and the McMichaels
there may be some differences but it
does not change the fact that was it not
for the fact
that Mr Brian used his vehicle in a way
to
impede Mr aubry's
uh
course of travel this may not have ever
occurred and that is sufficient for
felony murder
he did cooperate with law enforcement I
will point out Mr Goff 1710 1B there's
actually a case out of Chatham County
that says it would not apply under the
circumstances of this case
so the court recognizing that Mr Brian's
position is different again Mr Brian was
found not guilty on count one and count
two
Court sentences Mr Brian to life with
the possibility of parole on count three
count four is vacated count five is
vacated count six the defendant was
found not guilty count seven merges into
count three
defendant is sentenced to 10 years
consecutive to count three on count
eight and five years concurrent with
count eight
both of those counts though will be
suspended sentences ah
which gives Mr Brian a life with the
possibility of parole's sentence
those are the sentences
the court having pronounced sentence
first with regard to Travis McMichael
Mr McMichael you're hereby notified that
under the law of Georgia you are
entitled to appeal the guilty verdict of
the jury and if you decide to do so you
must file your appeal within 30 days of
this date
you are also informed that you have the
right to retain a lawyer of your own
choice to represent you on your
post-trial motions and appeals to the
appropriate Appellate Court of Georgia
if you cannot afford a lawyer the court
will appoint one for you you are
entitled to and will be given a
transcript of all pre-trial trial and
post-trial matters without cost to you
if you cannot afford a transcript
you may file a motion for a new trial or
you may appeal your case directly to the
appropriate Appellate Court of Georgia
for review you are also advised that the
statute of limitations for habeas corpus
in this state is four years in the case
of felonies and one year in the case of
misdemeanors the statute begins to run
from the date the conviction becomes
final
and just to be clear on the record I'm
going to go through the statement with
regard to each defendant so as to
Gregory McMichael you are hereby
notified that under the law of Georgia
you are entitled to appeal the guilty
verdict of the jury and if you decide to
do so you must file your appeal within
30 days of this date
you're also informed that you have the
right to retain a lawyer of your own
choice to represent you on your
post-trial motions and appeals to the
appropriate Appellate Court of Georgia
if you cannot afford a lawyer the court
will appoint one for you you are
entitled to and will be given a
transcript of all pre-trial trial and
post-trial matters without cost to you
if you cannot afford a transcript you
may file a motion for a new trial or you
may appeal your case directly to the
appropriate Appellate Court of Georgia
you are also advised that the statute of
limitations for habeas corpus in this
state is four years in the case of
felonies and one year in the case of
misdemeanors the statute begins to run
from the date the conviction becomes
final
and then finally Mr Brian
you are hereby notified that under the
law of Georgia you are entitled to
appeal the guilty verdict of the jury
and if you decide to do so you must file
your appeal within 30 days of this date
you are also informed that you have the
right to retain a lawyer of your own
choice to represent you on your
post-trial motions and appeals to the
appropriate Appellate Court of Georgia
if you cannot afford a lawyer the court
will appoint one for you you are
entitled to and will be given a
transcript of all pre-trial trial and
post-trial matters without cost to you
if you cannot afford a transcript you
may file a motion for a new trial or you
may appeal your case directly to the
appropriate Appellate Court of Georgia
for review
you're also advised that the statute of
limitations for habeas corpus in this
state is four years in the case of
felonies and one year in the case of
misdemeanors the statute begins to run
from the date the conviction becomes
final
don't have a blue or black pen is there
a blue or black pen down there
the court has executed the statement of
appeal
for
Travis McMichael
Greg McMichael
and William R Bryan
please have Council
and the defendants execute the
statements of appeal to confirm they've
been given are they notices been given
we'll summarize in a moment
very very serious sentences
so the Father and Son the McMichaels
life without parole
followed consecutively by 20 years
in practice
I believe the way it works is even if
somehow the life without parole is
vacated they've still got the 20 years
uh and Roddy Brian given life with
parole
plus a suspended sentence of 15 years
I imagine they will not be together
hanging out in prison that's my
understanding
[Applause]
anything further from the state
for a condition imposed along with this
sentence and that is this that the
defendants are not allowed to make any
money off of their actions such as a
book deal a movie deal social media deal
or anything along
any way shape or form make any money off
of this experience this conviction
and this trial and that should any money
be made that it go into a fund for the
Arbury family and I have I've had this
condition imposed before and given the
nature of this case we just seek to make
sure
that nobody gets any ideas
been found guilty of murder that they do
not then reap some sort of profit or
benefit off of their actions via such
renumeration
um to from to or from anyone in the form
of like I said book deals movie deals
um Consulting fees or telling their
story to someone in exchange for money
statute on this but maybe I'm wrong uh
it's not a Sam statue in other states
I'm not aware of George's if there is
um
yeah excited well yeah let's do this I I
submit something more formal to the
court I'll go ahead and take a look at
it
as well when the court does that uh my
only concern uh is how that would impact
Mr Ryan's ability to raise money for his
defense for his appeal
I wouldn't want to be in a situation
where he couldn't do that inadvertently
because of a sentencing condition yeah
now I understand the requests but I
without I don't want to just offhandedly
Grant the request without understanding
exactly what the terms are that the
court is seeking so I'd like something
in writing from the state explaining
what exactly the terms are that the
state would be seeking with regard to
the condition
and then I guess address that once
that's come in more formally with
defense counsel thank you
anything from Travis me Michael
from Greg McMichael from Mr Brian there
you are all right we are adjourned thank
you and there ends at least the first
case related
to the murder and we we do call it that
now the murder of Ahmad Arbury
and they have cut the feed here
um
well wow life without the possibility of
parole for both Travis and Gregory
McMichael
life with the possibility of parole for
Roddy Brian almost certainly will be
appealed I want to thank everybody who
joined me today that is going to end our
coverage of this today make sure you're
subscribed on YouTube or following on
Twitch so that when we cover future
trials events Etc
you will be notified and we will be live
again early next week I will see
everybody very very soon
foreign